foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
how my levels was going on oh man all
the oranges what's going on what's going
on
what's going on I need some mic checks
make sure the levels is good how we
sounding out here lazy attacker what's
going on all right all right Lillian
Master we got our animation Back the
Lords are moving looks like we got it
fixed
we was frozen for a minute Saloon salute
what's going on the line is being held I
appreciate you OG Joe back let's go oh
the fight is up in here we got some ogs
up in here from the chat that's what's
up a webinar game and I like that
witness the truth he said God how was
back people are losing it over star
field yeah yeah the Energy's in the
building Zach Riley what's going on pop
now yeah yeah we starting now we start
now
what's up brother how you doing man sex
slay at a homie appreciate you man give
me you always hook me up with that Tech
news that I need write you what's up
what's going on Chris all right all
right yeah it's gonna be a Go Happy
Father's Day yes absolutely absolutely
um well we got what we got joke Joe Coke
I have another DD episode running
another tab I was confused while I heard
you twice yeah this is the live one Joe
it's the real you know I'm saying
non-pre-recorded version of the car you
know what I'm saying how I can still
holding okay Black Room everybody
holding the line yeah the line has been
hellshire you know what I mean we're
gonna get it back to Lord's reunited
miss y'all it's been a minute since
we've all been together with travel and
all that good stuff big bad Mo what's up
David hot right what's up JC Insanity
what's going on Caboose what's up Mr Pro
ghostly what's going on what's up high
all right IOP family I see you now I
can't pronounce this name but I'ma try
churrasca chiroskia you saw Happy
Father's day what's going on Jose cuar
what's up Scotty what's up I see you
Cipher pole 92 yeah I like that name
that's a good rap battle then I made a
cipher pole in the in the building
Hold the Line oh friend yes oh he's a
storm cloak I like that name
Kick Kicking them dudes back
that's it all right no yeah I know what
that came from too Dallas man what's
going on that's the originals you about
to get next though oh you usually your
mom's phone you got
obviously I know I've been going through
some things but um I wanted men try to
turn this thing around yo make sure
y'all support man make sure y'all
support you know I'm doing my health as
well thing we got um I got a promo a
little bit we got the 30 uh for this
weekend so even if you don't like energy
drinks you don't like focus and all that
other stuff you don't want any of that
even though it's no you know it's
natural caffeine I would say go um go to
our Advanced boost line because those
are just straight up vitamins like
gummies like gummy bears and like gummy
bear form it's mad good they got the
multivitamins they got the vitamin D
which is really good they got um joint
support turmeric all app and if you just
care about multivitamins and health go
hit that link in the description if you
use iron Lord 30. 30 this weekend I
think this is the last day up until
midnight go check that out you know what
I'm saying get your health is both on so
you can start feeling good we need to be
around for these games y'all you got to
be around but anyway let me go snatch up
the rest of the Lords go see what's
going Young Chris what's going on Cali I
see
no doubt
um he said they porting Starfield over
to DaVita yo you stupid I can't what you
do that's that kid yeah um how useful to
join the joint supplements are really
good turmeric is really good for that
the joy supplement specifically they
have at Advanced boost is really good
for that you definitely want to get that
yeah powder get the powder I'm giving
powder to the people now giving powder
to the fever
Caboose yo Cog why is your boy Dustin so
salty even Crystal criticizing the Xbox
voiceover that man is entitled to his
opinion you know every everything for
everybody
so it is what it is like shout out to
Dustin you know no problems just like
he's on a I think his his mind said it's
kind of like yeah I gotta wait and see
Fallout 76 did um burn a lot of people
so I get that but for me that entire
team that's the B Team you know say
anything top is Mount Rushmore That's a
classic you know what I'm saying so you
got people got reminded we'll get it I
ain't gonna give you no more ball I
really got too much balls I just missed
talking to y'all but yeah we have the
guy held up yo y'all
anyway let me hurry up before Ken get in
here and get us demonetized the music
I'm gonna Snapchat addict solving the
building you know what I'm saying try to
get a nice nice little three-hour show
people got you know it's Father's Day
people got things to do we can't give
y'all six hours all the time we're gonna
see let's see okay cognitive Bill
Brownsville oh Brown
oh man that's the home of MLP oh man
we're sweet what up what's going on
that's for the town that's from the town
right there salute yeah yeah that line
was hell shout out to the Xbox
um Executives you know what I'm saying
doing anything it is love six hours it
is nah nah we can't do six man people
got
it's Father's Day man Forte what's up
that's that's another one right there
that's a good dad right there peace love
life dragon heart y'all best y'all miss
talking yeah this is what's up Severin
Evans all right all right all right I do
gotta go okay gonna come talk to y'all
in a minute we get y'all these Dallas
bars
[Music]
hear ye hear you man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go hit it up find
yourself a spot get comfortable grab a
snack do all the good stuff that we need
to do in um you know we're about to get
started I am well it's not important who
I am uh what's important is that you are
pulling up to the iron Lords podcast
right now as we speaking uh I guess I'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all for Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is
that Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call it
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them Reigns
you just a Target when I'm in the range
I was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back weed with
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell a uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headers be swearing it real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all feel Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that
[Applause]
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled put on the bo dog thing very
loyal but I ain't gonna hold you I ain't
heard the boy and you ain't gotta say it
I'm embarrassed for you I always been a
nerd never been a loser making Voltron
with
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be using these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start with regardless back
when you was messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still in
my Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers they don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Sample and making it
flammable this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rain you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social knowing my city but I'm
still by Coastal
[Music]
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled put on the bo dog thing very
loyal but I ain't gonna hold you I ain't
heard a boy and you ain't gotta say it
I'm embarrassed for you I always been a
nerd never been a loser Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and hell is be swearing ain't
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start it
regardless back weed with messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social lower my TV
but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but coming to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say I'm better than money because you
can Bank on me being accountable I know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
I kill a beat and they want to compare
me to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all too
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and Sample and
making it flammable this is that this is
that Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call it
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rains you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social knowing my city but I'm
still by Coastal I got you
[Music]
um
that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headers be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
arson up in the apartment they call it
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rain you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal I got you man
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that yoga
[Music]
radio radio
I'ma just chill and watch them and eat
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if I can imagine it's cool to get
you some advice and invite your girl to
your squadron cause if you don't give
her that option you're gonna be single
player like Cyrus you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by King David
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental was an avatar to a knee
Bender I gotta be me though I know it's
my destiny word to kind needle who cares
if he fly if you stealing mosquito you
swear you ain't nothing but really be
Stevo you like to collect stuff and
that's cool but I got bad news even if
he really was that Joe King David still
be the king of the statue sister
juvenile I've been cursed with a curse
to be Musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in The Crucible other than nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this
and you're cubicle on the Lord
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord's Day
[Music]
all right all right all right my checks
real quick let's make sure the mic's a
good reunited I had to talk to the
people man what's going on guys what's
going on
with that
hola hola and the king is the king we
have seen him already we are good yeah
yeah here you hear ye and we are live
Happy Father's Day for all the
Patriarchs out there in the realm we
respect your service enjoy your day and
welcome to the iron Lords podcast LLC
and also live on lordsofgaming.net
that's super chat is wild happy Saturday
day y'all wallet
episode number 309 yes Kai 309 we're
accounting the other two are audio
listeners you have to go to YouTube If
you if you're on 307 but anyway
and it's another glorious Sunday we are
back at the round table on the Lord's
date and today we've got the Xbox
showcase and Starfield direct aftermath
Final Fantasy 16 demo Impressions Rog
Ally Impressions and PlayStation 5 Cloud
streaming to discuss so we gonna get
right into it wise kick laughing
so let's get you doing stuff for a horse
bit of a gaming those original Lords of
the round finally reunited at the round
table it feels like it's been a minute
and it feels so good everybody had their
announcement everybody it was either
that or the Wu-Tang yeah oh yeah
I go I learned a lot about attic this
trip like you buffing that NF he he a
hip hop on the low don't sleep with my
man but anyway yeah Backpacker yeah but
like I go for the dude he put me on I
know something was nice like that but
anyway my co-host with the call Mouse my
brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his old
world and the how of the young wolf my
man Lord attic back to back how we doing
oh my God people now I got a day right
here I gotta deal with that here I have
people commenting on my videos saying
nice back-to-back video format
it was cut it was it's classic it's
going on man how are we doing we're
doing pretty good man we have a pretty
good shot uh we have a pretty good show
for you guys today you know I I I've
played that beta for Final Fantasy 16
like five times so uh you know let's go
into that you know what's funny I didn't
realize how many people
like value my final fantasy opinions
until this damn demo came out like I got
that BG asked me to come on weapon wheel
to talk about Final Fantasy had people
cut people mad comedy like they're
sitting there like what is is addict
gonna talk about it on the podcast this
week asking me am I gonna talk about it
have I played it it's just yes I have
played it I've played it multiple times
you know why right because they they
consider us an Xbox podcast
because of my fault and they act like uh
through extension you saying or anything
PlayStation is good it's like let's see
a show let's show an Xbox guy Final
Fantasy he's not one of us he's he's
mixed with one of y'all okay so that's
not a victory for you
yeah now that I think it's it's Final
Fantasy definitely Fable when anything
Fable related people
got me on the Xbox brand but Final
Fantasy made me a game and then me and
you I remember with the Remake we were
so in all what was going on we talked
about I was like what does that mean
what is that we sit there attic breaking
certain level yeah you certain games
that's clearly your pocket so that's
been it just the demo sir yeah just a
demo I could go into more stuff uh I've
been playing a lot of persona 5. trying
to finish that game once and for all
Xbox I I've literally played the first
like four palaces like multiple times
but I'm not gonna go too much into that
because I I want to be out here by three
today
I I don't got kids
I don't care about the children I don't
care about the children I just want to
be out anyway and of course of those
technical gaming Lord the solar Gable
list for the single player selfish
experience and also the sastra Davis the
Lord of clarity and Lord patreon of the
iron bank PC Master races old rock Ally
Lord Sovereign How We Do It yeah the
fomo got me
throw it up damn it throw it up throw it
up
damn it no I know it's serious one oh
wow that's that's big for him because he
ate a PC kind of yeah he don't run out
there frivolously with his money yeah
but again it's a we'll talk about it
later but it's a special thing to have
something that that feels like an Xbox
uh portable right it feels like it is
you know you know when I explained it to
you you might think differently I I
understand we get to that part but it's
The Unofficial official you know what
I'm saying we openly dating yeah it's
true Xbox they were part of the
presentation exactly the same thing with
the the gcloud you know Xbox Xbox is in
um
they practicing polygamy with head
healthy you understand like they they
kind of Mormon like this
yeah what
is
to be able to you know uh afford the
situation don't be out there being cheap
with one you know what I'm saying so
that's why the G cloud is loved in this
space I was King gonna tell me to give
him my time
it's a topic we like yeah that's both
specializing taking my time everybody
IPS is soft second everybody is always
never finished then they want to act
like they said it too yeah yeah
I have to get a history of IOP and again
I'm cutting use off right now I'm
literally cutting you right now
in the history I don't think we've ever
went to your segment without us
interrupting one time you know what you
know what king it's it's okay keep going
what I want to do one week I want one
week we all collude and don't say
nothing
no it's messed up because then I'm used
to having to cut in when y'all come back
continue something on that so yeah we'll
talk about the rock in a bit um I was
supposed to play lies of Pete that ain't
happen it downloaded very well though
um but it looks pretty I did play
literally I played 15 minutes of it and
what I did play of it was it was very
polished like super polished um I'll
have more to say next week but it as an
Xbox day one game pass thing looking
very very nice it's just gonna be a
matter you know how picky the souls born
players are if it's if it's an easy game
they're gonna be mad at it you know if
it's if it's too similar they're gonna
be mad at it uh but art style and just
to polish the overall polish of the demo
will have people running it oh I ran it
150 frames per second or something crazy
stuff though
um that's cool uh what else I played
some of the ff16 demo okay impressed
with that as well although um so I put
it on performance mode right we'll talk
about that oh yeah so yeah so I in case
you get you guys didn't know but King
knows uh the baby arrived so I have the
TV right now
finally so it has in game mode it has a
thing that pop up and it shows you all
the stats of whatever you're running
yeah so performance mode and hit 60.
yeah it's not it's it's like hovering at
55 and I see it because when I you know
you spin around you pan around yeah and
it just starts doing the Boogaloo so
um so yeah so that but again I'm still
impressed with what that game is it's
very you know very uh A Game of Thrones
issue but I'm enjoying it and yeah we
got to see the flash yesterday
um enhance it because my TV when when
game mode hits you okay so you have the
the [__] like you talk about right
anguished
my bad you have the little thing that's
in the corner that you're talking about
and then you can see where they picking
up the the back end like the bottom like
I see those numbers so your TV is doing
it right so the TV the TV is doing it
because it has it's on a 120 hertz mode
there is a smoothing mode that I don't
like because it kind of it gets moves
over like textures and I really don't
like the what it does it's probably the
move there being King like continue yeah
yeah I mean it's running at 120 hertz
and the TV goes up to 144 Hertz oh God
oh God so it's just it's just the game
not hitting it and the thing is for the
most part it's smooth like running
around it's smooth but when I just
noticed it always winter parents and and
now and it'll go smoothly for a little
bit and then it'll hit you a little bit
and then go back to smooth so it's not
often but enough where I was like this
ain't 60 and then as soon as I hit the
game mode to see this the stats I was
like oh yeah no 60 no 60. so maybe the
final product will be but it's not it's
not quite there yet
um and yeah we started flash yesterday
went to the class with uh Lord marlonius
kaibatsu and and Cog I I enjoyed it for
what it is there was a lot of fan
service
a lot of people are not again continue
to be disgusted with Ezra Miller
but I like the fan service I got to see
some faces I never thought I would say
yeah that was crazy don't sound like he
liked it okay King looks out that he's
disgusted with it no what if he walked
down oh
apparently black apparently Black Adam
made more money opening weekend than it
are you serious yeah and so did the
Green Lantern
no no so you know what that's that's an
Ezra Miller thing that is people oh yeah
yeah
he actively he's the villain
it was funny we're giving Kyle a little
bit a little bit of crap for it
yesterday because it was obvious that he
was especially disgusting with this
portrayal because of his love for the TV
version of flash right yes so he was
like he did not like it at all
we always got to over at least they
fixed the gliding the gliding
what was funny though is when he tried
to do it
would be crazy King yeah you know be
crazy if they it when they rebr when
they reboot flash if they cast him as
reverse reverse flags
and he's kidnapping people in the mood I
I enjoyed it for what it is I don't know
that it really
I don't know I'll give you a little
something yeah yeah but that's it that's
it that's it but again uh excited to uh
this game's coming out ladies and
gentlemen oh this game's coming out oh
yeah no doubt and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the access
gamer
the prophet of Xbox Swami King of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of everyone's Hold the Line movement
beloved Lord King how we doing
oh man first everybody that picked up a
Hold the Line shirt thank you
I don't even have mine
where's my homie
I got some minutes oh yeah I forgot to
put mine up you know it arrived on
Tuesday oh damn yeah we hold it we hold
it we hold it I want to say um thank you
for everybody that did that
um and thank you for everybody that was
in Cali that you know wanted me to be
there but I thought Sunday's show where
kids move uh 108 dragons solving myself
was monumental
for all the people that were here we had
over a thousand likes but before the
show was over we had 1300 watching right
now it's sitting at
2174. I am you know
um
I just say thank you for everybody that
came out just to hear our uh reactions
to see our reactions to a show that that
meant a lot
um I just want to give a really quick
man talk to a lot of you
it's just real quick just real quick
um I saw somebody going at 108 dragons
because of his age
you know um aren't you like 50 that's
cringe as as AF
um that you know he put on the Starfield
uh helmet and have on the Starfield suit
um first one y'all don't know what
cringe is you're using this word I find
this this
this age of child or children ignorant
as hell
um
you don't get to an age and then drop
who you were from when you were born
right maturity comes through yeah you
don't do certain things like see like me
if I was 16 years old you call me cringe
I smack the hell out of you
um that is true
and be like what do you mean by it right
so that's that's the age difference
that's how age goes right Aid with age
should come wisdom correct now that
doesn't mean that you lose the child
inside of you because the child inside
of you won't be picking up video games
because video games technically is an
escape from reality so therefore you're
in a childlike State
um understand your place
video games aren't made for children
because they wouldn't cost five hundred
dollars
you know to be able to purchase because
I've never seen a baby with a job
this man is giving back and because
either you can't move in that space or
you don't find that humor funny
you feel that you have to age shame him
like he's acting out of his age keep the
wonderment in you keep the child like uh
Essence in you and that way you
understand life would be a whole lot
less stressful yeah all your life you
want to grow up
but when you get old enough to handle
responsibilities and bills you're going
to want to go back to when you didn't
have so
um all I'm saying is
gaming is for every age I want to see 90
year old people with wrong allies and
and virtual reality programs
having fun
this this space is for everyone
regardless of age so don't do that don't
try to shame somebody because of the age
and I'm not saying it because I'm a Gray
beard no no but like that to add on to
your wisdom you know what I'm saying
because the kingdom remember we've put
up the demographic or remember like
what's the most growing and one of the
biggest communities right now I know I
tease the attic a little bit and it was
the 40 something I was like yo they are
like the one of the biggest groups as
far as the pushes the pushes the coaches
because we have the disposable income to
actually maintain a service correct
while y'all guys are trying to figure
out how the hell you're going to play
your Netflix oh we paid it for the year
so again
um just don't age him all right Father's
Day let's go let's go Happy Father's Day
to every father out there so a lot of
you fathers are going through some stuff
at the moment and I understand because I
might be going through the same things
with you but at no point in time does
that take away from what you have done
as a father and who you are so if no one
is looking over at you today saying
Happy Father's Day I I'm looking at you
brother and uncle or cousin or whoever
Happy Father's Day you have value so
thank you for everything that you do
everything that you don't get credit for
and sometimes you don't get that that
mail or whatever that you that you
looking for for appreciation I
appreciate you and your efforts and
everything you do thank you so much
this weekend brother I saw the Flash
um
I love the fact that they use four to
five different comic books to put this
movie together they use crisis on
infinite Earth they use Flashpoint they
use uh this a Superman uh when he got
captured in the alternate universe
um and two other Batman uh Batman love
was in the building yes I I thought it
was a great Michael Keaton film I
thought it was a terrible Ezra Miller
film fair fair it makes sense
um and this is a great way to end
what used to be the Zack Snyder
um this this was a perfect way to end it
I'm glad that they didn't throw the film
away because you it could have easily
been thrown away like Batgirl and I'm
glad that it wasn't I'm not saying that
I support anything that Ezra Miller has
done or is accused of doing or you know
filed out of court with what I'm saying
is I thought this movie needed to be
told for the fan service that it did get
it gave you something that we never
thought that we would see as comic book
collectors as uh DC fans and superhero
fans I encourage people to go see it
it's not as bad as we are making it out
to be but
it's laughable and it's some DC stuff
that you feel that is going to be I've
been playing Diablo
um couldn't even get to fortnite every
time I've been trying to get to fortnite
Diablo has my soul
uh it's one of the and people ask me yo
I'm gonna join in with you I don't want
you to join me
because I want I want to experience this
it's so much fun like listening to us
single player Diablo
after you end it then you call your
friends in right is that because that's
what I do like I like this story I like
yo go over there because the dude with
the hatchet then kill my baby yeah then
you gotta go again
I don't want nobody triggering some
event while I'm in the middle of a story
so this is so much fun I can't wait till
the season pass kicks off I was asking
solved uh I don't know if you answered
me in the DM
I make oh God I was already at the movie
I completely forgot to answer you I
think I got you like the middle tier one
yeah that's the one but it comes with
that season pass stuff right I don't
know I gotta check we'll figure it out
we'll figure it out yeah because I'm
getting nervous because it didn't go
into my PM right now
he was like he was like yo oh next loaf
I can't wait for it to start the season
pass and formal in my heart immediately
I was like oh season pass what are you
talking about I said let me check and
see if I'm in this but um that game
man I can't wait for Microsoft to buy
ABK so it's released in soccer
but that's all I've been doing I can't
wait for the collectors uh we had dcx
this Friday night
um it was if you go check to the dcx
channel you can see us talking about
statues
you PlayStation dudes thought I was
coming at you guys for that Spider-Man's
crappy uh thing with the plastic PVC
what I was trying to explain to you guys
is save your money or if you want to get
a real Statue buy the digital version of
the of the game
and go buy a real Statue right
um like I have real statues like I got
Spider-Man in here that's the one from
the video game the Spider-Man video game
but go buy a real statue that actually
has value and then you can actually sell
a statue if you don't need it you can't
sell at PVC stuff that you get in the
game box nobody wants that crap and we
find it in Best Buy months later for
what 90 off Jeep yeah yeah you I got
Master Chief helmets you saw those two
Master Chief helmets that I got the
first time I paid for I paid like 250
next time I went inside Best Buy it was
like a month or a couple of months later
a year later
I got it for 37.50
yeah and that's how I realized how cheap
this stuff is and you do no resale value
is nothing they capitalize on our fomo
they're in our wallets and I was saying
it as a as a guy standing against uh
capitalism on the weak man uh it's
financially and they they capitalize on
your fomo by the game but buy a real
Statue or something that you can really
display that has some real value that
you can get rid of later and that's how
you do it in in the money terms you know
why do we say king is dead or incorrect
but I still got it I know you did and um
we're working on you because I'm gonna
go to your collection we're gonna get
rid of all that well we gotta get rid of
him
you know cause you spend a lot of money
so you're gonna you're gonna step up
your PVC oh man we [__] watching I
gotta pocket watch that cause my man got
I can't go do his camera he looks better
wild bread not to put your business out
there guidelines and all this and got
Funko Pops
don't come from a man with the fun pop
don't do that that's my dude man but
we're gonna have a Funko Pop section
we're gonna keep that small
your XM Studio Sideshow that's what we
said we gonna get you there all right
fair enough yeah I forget well yeah
we'll talk about it all right back stuff
after that yeah
put it out there yeah don't put that up
okay your version's support
yo you playing the Xbox One version oh
maybe playing this Super Bass no texture
no textures no no ketchup no nothing
anyway and of course we have the gaming
ninja himself the Shinobi Lord cognito's
friend that Rose to the Roman IOP not
telling what you wanted but what you
need to hear first off
um shout out to everybody who pulled up
on me and at it outside you know what I
mean like as far as you know summer game
fast Xbox game showcase the community
came out in droves you know it was it
was just so cool like again you know as
people who've done real E3 nothing's
ever going to replace that energy but
just the whole you know being in
specific spots and at any point you can
see your favorite content created right
you could see you know Executives
whether it be from Xbox or whoever and
then um shout out to the LSM and IOP
communities you know coming up to us you
know coming up to me hey you know we
love the content you know everybody
asking for kick itself where the rest of
the Lord said you know hold the light
out here moving and you know shout out
to greeny man oh man it was just it was
really amazing to see the community kind
of kind of ride the movement and just
get behind it and it was just fun it
just it was the closest thing to a
capsule to to eat three of them for me
obviously personally you know mentally
I've been going through physically I've
been going through some stuff and uh I
needed that trip I needed to see people
I needed to get out and uh it was cool
to have addict every day I haven't put
the boy the Boy even gave me a gym day
y'all he gave me some iron you know what
I'm saying in the gym you know what I'm
saying he's like yo we had to do I'm
Gonna Get Up On My Own Day drink you
know what I'm saying
he's a beast like I mean even doing
cardio like I have to look up to him
like bro like there's even no way I
could do it without music and then he's
doing it for the length he's doing it
I'm just like yo he's a [__] yeah so
salute the attic was doing a little
Health his wealth as far as me um yeah
just been rocking as much as I can
obviously we got that Ally we will talk
about that been playing everything with
Allah I want to shout you our attic um
there's a game uh that went into Game
Pass
um I'm embarrassed I've never played it
was from double fine I never played
massive chalice
so it's amazing it took me a long time
to beat that game that game is and you
know it's funny because I looked at my
list you know Xbox tells you you have
friends that play this game and it had
your day I was like how adequate tell me
about this I was mad you put me on
Twitter
I'm old I forgot
he put his head I told you old self
about it
this is this is nothing new I talked
about Dishonored I know how many times
it took Maddie to tell him to play it is
it where he played it otherwise he's not
playing that game no it was really the
red four thing that forced him into that
yeah
like what happened like and then what I
saw what happened I said oh this is why
people are mad
salute to that I've been doing that
obviously um like I talked about Final
Fantasy 16 demo we will get into that
and then oh yeah that's pretty much it
so um oh real quick because I got to do
some little thing yo iron Lords man 30
off right now go get I am more 30 get
your Advanced GT right now we pushing P
yeah
you focus you focus man holla at me man
you got your focus you know what I'm
saying so we got some got some new
flavors real quick you know what I'm
saying got that that Spartacus that
Titan the Titan blood you gotta get that
Tiger's Bluff you a Lord that fruit
punch tigers blood this is official
right now get your focus on you know
it's called coffee
please do please do it all right so I'm
not getting paid from these dudes so I'm
not going to tell you exactly who they
are but this is coconut water yeah and
what I've noticed is
um if you don't want to drink dead water
Supreme health
you can rehydrate with coconut water in
this it gives it the best taste amazing
yeah amazing and you could even put that
even if you don't want no caffeine
you're a person that can't do the
caffeine energy drink kind of thing you
can mix your low coconut water with
dehydration and hydrationism which cause
supplement as well which is kind of like
oh you know when you just want a little
flavor they got electrolytes in it so
you got that and then for me because you
know your boy got there you know we've
announced we've gone through a medical
thing so with the diverticulitis so this
is the energy the non-probiotic stuff
the no fat probiotics probiotics are
good for you that gives you that's
actually the good bacteria yeah for your
gut health you know what I'm saying yeah
use it today
so we can get everybody they they boost
on so we're gonna do that I like my
gummies too man yeah oh yeah we're gonna
get to the guys
all right we'll get to the gummies now
so get your gummies on we got the
multivitamin we got the joy supports
this is to go to the advanced boost get
your health on and then you can get your
vitamin D pause
you get your vitamin D you know say
powder you know what I'm saying get that
golden vitamin D yeah DJ orals he gonna
get that yo don't be mixing Crown Royal
yo you Wilding you talk about it yeah
it is
okay relax yourself bro
DJ will literally DJ will literally take
shots between Fallout Fall Guy rounds
like yeah and for those of you that
don't know a fog guys around might last
two minutes so take a shot between them
between rounds he's literally taking
probably 10 shots in like three games
djr is a little too focused with a
little bit too much hydration powder to
the people I'm gonna tell you right now
Okay we okay what we gonna start doing
this first we're gonna get an agent
facts all right and we're gonna start uh
runs out today so you get that 30 off
all right Lord sale go check that out
anyway
so what you got man father to the people
okay covers let me read these super
chats first because when I get into the
other business I got some serious
fighting going on in the chat too what
happened what's going on
the crown in the Royale with the pretty
workout what they working with are they
bad
why you got quiet what happened no JD
Gamers going at someone in the chat oh J
yeah yeah I see yeah JD she busted his
guns chest out there yeah it's a lot
it's a lot going though you know it's a
very Victorious week for something
that's happy with the Victory lap so to
speak but let's go but we got all right
so this first one is from last week the
last one that came in last week after we
went uh we we went off the air because
we don't have you know we we could not
go back on there after I saw this that
was it so this is Robert kellett five
dollar Super Chat Xbox doing a
spider-verse art style before
PlayStation fire south of midnight looks
stunning I can't wait to see more of
that Atlas being there was huge yes it
was Sir I agree so Atlas building with
you uh was there a six yeah I mean I saw
a new IP you know he did say that he
wasn't about the best was it the sixth
iteration of that IP no it wasn't the
six but I mean some people said that you
know the answer is Sag no six no news
listen listen I think six is going in
there I think this is just four
shadowing it if you beat me on that and
I will I will gladly give up the knees
all right he's doing The King and I love
that
I don't know I just remember when you
know I was getting jumped by a certain
person and ACG you know the singer the
cloud partnership was just nothing it's
nothing about games it's just okay
you know I gotta come back for you of
course
yo let's show them that we can actually
have a one-to-one ratio with those likes
and um that'll be hard what animal we
saving for the likes today what are we
doing I want to save the Siberian
platypus
hit that like button we're having fun
it's Father's Day you know what I'm
saying people got things to do with
their family come on the play the
PlayStation Fanboys have locked General
King in in jail man those likes is how
he gets out of prison
y'all better hold the line on these
likes
anyway
hold on look at the chat South Forever
This is BET on more now than the FDC
Market thank you thank you y'all
remember the parameters were is there a
six
one bad mother they jumped me I never
forget attic but you was there it was
him and ACG and they jumped me and it
was like this announcement is only Cloud
there's nothing game related coming from
this I had to eat that I'm like all
right all right shout out to Sarah
she is all right uh Necromancer sale
member for 19 months long gold after
many driver updates patches Windows
updates and setting changes by Asus Rog
Ally is running great I'm not not the
best out of the box experience though
non-techies be warned love it besides
that yeah who is that that wrote that
that's fair that was necromancers
and those device first yeah yes
I heard some things I can't wait to get
to that segment
then we have a couple of niggles
whoa whoa whoa
yo you pushing the line sir I know where
you I know I know what he do I know they
got that from
is going to be trash and you know it
oh man then we have the list 22 remember
for 28 bus Lauren bronze Happy Father's
Day to all the fathers out there and
anyone who is a father figure in a
child's life salute to all of you today
yeah absolutely people get it messed up
that you have to be a biological father
yo a lot of times you don't know
you are affecting a kid because they
they're looking they're watching they're
seeing and you just don't know who
you're affecting day-to-day you might be
a father figure of somebody you just
don't even know realize it no that's
true
we got Michael Santiago five dollars
which aka the tune medication
Happy Father's Day to all the fathers in
The Gaming Community as a first time
gamer dad I now gotta choose which games
I play buy 100 hour RPGs yes concessions
must be made excellent man that's the
homie right there yeah they put up
pictures of today it's first Father's
Day so he's elated man
see you soon I haven't even been on
Twitter yet yeah it's crazy then we got
Robert Kelly again five dollar Super
Chat hello Lords has any of you play the
ff16 demo I enjoyed it a lot dark tone
really fun combat amazing visual
stunning music and it runs great mostly
great we will talk about it definitely
talk about that demo there we got Robert
kellett two dollar Super Chat once again
congrats on being the face of Xbox
General King yes yes hold the line with
everything
yeah bro like how did it feel to see the
community you know let's be keeping it
let's keep it a stack when it wasn't
looking good you know what I'm saying at
the FTC CMA block red fall disaster
Everybody's scared the death of the
PlayStation showcase but wasn't General
stood up it's 78 firing nobody we gonna
hold this line and this C Xbox get
behind it you know what it is it's
validation talk to right um a lot of
people don't know my character so I'm
not a backdown dude
you put pressure I'm the wrong person to
put pressure on because I don't care
what type of pressure you putting I'm
gonna double down and give you back the
same energy and put back more pressure
when I saw individuals
and with some individuals that I thought
I respected I don't anymore
um talk about oh you know I'm leaving
Xbox I'm getting getting past
I said enough is enough
like enough is enough like y'all making
a bigger thing that out of something and
you you don't know well what business is
you don't know how anything goes I know
the machine that's over there at
Microsoft and I know exactly what
they're going to do and I'm gonna double
down because
um if anybody saw
the only company and shout out to Jeff
Kegley
but I'm talking about a console maker
the only console maker that respected
tradition was Microsoft
they respected E3 that week is a
tradition yeah so when when Phil says
the P Hines I mean not be Heinz um uh
this dude over at uh Sony nice show good
show but whatever
keep up that show Spirit right but get
out there and dude and he put the work
in we got to start rewarding the ones
that's rewarding us
so I just saw I'm not gonna stand there
and let I'm not gonna ride with you and
then when it get rough then you out I'm
out facts it's easy to ride when it's
good times so now what it looks like
what it looks like when you reaping the
spoils baby To the victor goes what's
the Troy live you don't dare to be great
nobody ain't gonna never remember your
name
so if anybody see all King hold a lot I
don't even know who that is that's oh
that's what's up oh geez what's up I'm a
ride with OG that's right if you don't
stand for something you'll fall for
anything but it's better to go down on
your Shield whoa did it go down running
because I see dudes right now they pull
dudes out the closet like an old mood
we got we captured y'all so he on our
side over there and they got the happy
selfish
over here you gonna drag my dead body
down the block cause I lost that way at
least you're gonna be like we got them
you ain't gonna be no prison no more
give up
I respect the real ones Aaron Greenberg
whoa
you are a real one facts I respect you
so much because he had on that shirt he
was holding the lines it's giving credit
this Gene Park
it's like
man it's just so much respect to every
everyone that's about this and you know
exactly who you are so if I'm not saying
everybody I'm I do apologize but I
respect y'all and I'm telling you when
the ABK deal goes through oh that's next
oh you dudes don't want to see me
movement is moving it's a beautiful
thing oh no it's Alex love you oh yeah
every content created something give
love you give bars to um what's the kid
oh man it did the back to back you know
yeah yeah
something I think yeah salute that your
anecdotum yeah like whoever used the
clip and just had fun
yeah like
yeah some dudes go talk about uh shout
out to the Queen Sarah Bond yeah she
said Advance the line like it's so it's
a movement and it's beautiful to see you
know what I'm saying it's so beautiful
one last thing I say about you I got to
give you this is that it's off you know
growing up like you're never gonna put
them in a box and when he believes in
something wholeheartedly like it reminds
me of when the whole Hood was like Tyson
was going to kill Holyfield for years
Holyfield and only Kingston now I'm
riding like what he going and when it
happened that was one of the greatest
moments with kid just to see me and him
in a room I think we did it with Tito we
did it with Trinidad we was at two yeah
okay
so let me tell you something I've always
mean him me and just just me and him has
always been back to back
remember
I was Mexican Brothers
yeah I was in a whole movie theater with
at least a thousand Mexican facts I'm
the only one screaming Oscar gonna kill
him and Oscar killed him Tito Tito was
good I don't know it was Oscar versus
um
the first time the first time
yeah we're uh uh Sweet Pea versus Oscar
we killing it was me and you
let me tell you
always hostile environments I'm always
going to stand ten toes down always
going to believe in what we believe in
and and I'm telling you this man I know
this for a fact this even hcl's gonna go
through and you're all gonna have
hayachi face always I can't wait for the
facts
yeah you've always saw it with Xbox
you've always saw it with Phil and I
will give you that so anyway I know we
got we're killing kill him sorry sorry
about that you got me till three and I'm
out I'm with you I'm with you too good
to you good to you all right so where
was he I lost tracks all right the ex
Don Dio Taco five dollar Super Chat
Final Fantasy 16 is everything I hate in
gaming 80 of the demo was cut scenes
qtes everywhere and a cinematic boss
battle where you hold one button trash
Oh my God come on now come on I noticed
your Zelda love feel a little threatened
I I get it this game of the year thing
is it's hitting up for a lot of people
that I'm just saying
your project Aries remember for one
month two dollar Super Chat happy zaddy
day to the old fathers of the room thank
you appreciate it all sugar daddies
Happy Days
time
so there you have Robert Kelly again two
dollars to protest so no eight hour epic
fam no no no not today there they
happened there we got Sith Lord remember
for 10 months Lord bronze Happy Father's
Day to the ones who hashtag hold the
line that showcase was fire Xboxes on
track wait till next year is over all
thanks to King David love you guys thank
you
what up baby Cali I see your vote for
that family out there I would love shout
out to the whole crew request yo all at
the bad Titan all that what's the roast
IOP Wes those are my day one salute
y'all
then we got Robert Kelly again today at
Xbox the sugar daddy of handhelds yeah
I definitely dropped the bag off to to
Asus
then we got slo-mo backslap remember for
two years five dollars to be tapped
massive entertainment doing what Bungie
can't do showcase two brand new AAA
games in one showcase shout out to the
better more versatile Studio shout out
to that unreleased game what's the
engagement numbers on the Play account
yeah let's get to the facts though
then we have DJ Ross book for two years
ten dollars to be chat long time listen
to The First Time
love the Lord's day how about that rock
Rog Ally no sketchy stuff 10 out of 10
would recommend Diablo 4 10 out of 10
would recommend IOP 10 out of 10 would
recommend hey bestie Hey DJ what's going
on my Ally that's my Ally salute then we
got Robert Kelly again five dollar Super
Chat ff16 at 30 FPS actually felt fine
to me 60 FPS spoilers Yoshi P did say a
day one patch is coming thankfully so it
should be fixed up by launch yeah
hopefully
thank you brother appreciate you then we
got Gerald Mack remember for two years
2000 with that I'm 50 plus them
youngsters don't know ish that's right
right with you buddy then we got hargit
Cindy remember for one year five dollar
Super Chat we need to get Phil Dominus a
special hashtag Hold the Line shirt King
wish we had a bunch of shirts to give
away out in L.A Happy Father's Day to
all dads and that would have been crazy
bro salute to hoggy man it was so fun
hanging out with him like that whole
trip but yeah I'm sorry continuing no
that's just my thing is he doesn't dress
himself so he could have a bunch of
shirts he could have went to the store
and brought life four or five shirts but
unless we catch him out in the wild
okay you don't think he gotta adhere to
it sometimes shout out to hexan shout
out to hexa shout out to accident yeah
for real
stop [__] watching me bro because
I'ma do this again and again and again
keep up or shut up oh my god dad said
have a wonderful Lord today
but what everybody loves Father's Day
now let the rewards pour it oh let's
keep it low let's keep it low shout out
to everybody shout out to everybody okay
let's let's stop it
Fearless though man let's put the crust
in the chat for the newest member of the
realm Lord bronze Fearless Nomad thank
you appreciate you mm-hmm we got void
lock remember for 18 months Lord brought
use the likes to save the Unicorn who
lost their horns
wow
I forgot about that I forgot about that
black that is hilarious coin that lost
his arms yeah
a Savage with that continue we got Craig
hooligan uh uh stick a member for six
months gifted one IOP membership thank
you so much appreciate that but the
Crush in the chat and actually Craig
hooligan once again gifted another
membership so shout out to you two
memberships from Craig hooligan salute
plural
[Laughter]
then we got deaf side you remember uh so
put the crust in the chapter Dev side
gifted and IOP membership as well thank
you so much appreciate that salute
see we got anything that popped in here
I think he did you think you got Shady
gamer just gifted like gamer gifted 10.
I don't remember
yeah I got to go back okay Astro parrot
King five dollar Super Chat met my
biological father for the first time
yesterday wow oh wow went to the A's
game on over 11 out of 30 stadiums done
having hashtag lfgm Go Cubs Go kind of
day
absolutely that's a beautiful thing
beautiful thing love that Sports
pilgrimage just dope never too late
never too late and we have 108 dragons
TV two dollar Super Chat Ally Alliance
stand up yeah
[Music]
is coming
don't disrespect then put ff16 in the
ring with tears of the Kingdom that's a
middleweight changing the kingdom and
Starfield are the only ones fighting for
heavyweight Champs
I just play that game all I'm saying is
play the game I think the competition is
is gonna be finished this year I'm gonna
tell you right now Diablo 4 got
something to say yeah people act like
Diablo not Idiot I'm with you [__] it
like this is listen man
there's a lot of people that love these
different styles of games and it's going
to be very contentious but of course
Zelda Starfield in a mix of course it's
just Zelda disqualified itself oh come
on now graphically when everybody can
spin the block on it like and then you
got to go down to the gameplay it's a
diversity and then you're gonna say they
stole it from nuts and bolts so
um I'm just like it was a nice try wow
but um it's nice it's nice it's a nice
try but
this day and age we gotta demand better
wow yeah
we're just not gonna sit there and say
because the limitations of the cost
that's on them Jack we're gonna speak in
a limited we're going to talk about
limitations on certain others things
that you represent
sir
here's the kingdom no uh continue
then we have ice cold cabbage
[Music]
I just want to thank David for the labs
she's giving me over this showcase
period I know it's not much but thank
you sir laughter is everything if you
can laugh you everything will be all
right I appreciate you for giving me
that ice cold cabin
[Laughter]
thank you IOP for the good work and to
thank you for that I got that IOP
Valarie hello
going to have alarms watching we only
got 400 that's half of you I know the
other half can hit the like button
subscribe share it out come on now
the house just hit the like button
please ring my doorbell to come in we
got food in here it's real nice
you gotta get you some Focus
get a Volari pillow on the way out Lord
news cold Lord 15. and anyway
remind him right quick and we have
question what happened to all the god
Sims games like populist from dust and
black and white are at Peter lionhead
Studios great games hold the line I
don't know I want them to come back yeah
we you need a Peter modeling you and a
whatchamacallit
this is where we at now so
that's three hundred dollars then we
have the bougie coin
[Laughter]
enjoying Sunday with my man and holding
the Line south of midnight is going to
be fire hashtag gamer girlfriend hashtag
Xbox forever hashtag ain't no switching
up
um
that's what I'm talking Riders
appreciate that no doubt let me see him
go back make sure we didn't get anything
else you know we got X down the attack
we'll get five dollars I played the game
and it's not the same level can you not
try to talk about limitations but I know
you're gonna cap the stuff
that one star Phil over there though I
saw a petition
we're taking it 15 frames
you take nothing
over here we have Dragonheart yo
remember for 23 months Lord of gold
hashtag peace love life wanted to tell
y'all I reconnected with my auntie and
grandmother on my father's side we're in
the early stages of building a
relationship it was on my mind for years
now it's possible yes it is
a blessing yeah
and then I don't know if I read this one
Fearless Nomad gifted one IOP membership
thank you
there's no mad JD gamer we just did that
one yes and we got caught up so now
oh we got okay
Diablo and ff16 when we Game of the Year
level tears of the Kingdom in Starfield
like I want to be game of the generation
level fighting games of the next gen yo
stop trying to connect that joint with
my joint
it's only when you said game of the
generation there's only one in that
category it damn sure ain't Vaseline oh
man stop putting Vaseline up as tribute
yeah
you gotta stop calling that game that
you're stupid
nobody use that no more
disrespectful last one Alvin five dollar
Super Chat ff16 is a 20-hour action game
I want to play on top of 30 hours of
cutscenes I don't want to watch past
hashtag
let me mute myself
let us be quiet in the realm
one moment okay
support for the iron Lords podcast is
brought to you by manscaped who is the
best in men's below the waist grooming
the products of precision and in the
engineered tools for your family jewels
manscapes performance package the
ultimate men's hygiene bundle joined
over 8 million men worldwide who trusted
manscaped with this exclusive offer for
you 20 off and free worldwide shipping
with the code iron Lords at manscape.com
if my math is correct that's about 16
million balls
so the acorns the coin purse Deez Nuts
the Glizzy companions the Family Jewels
and the giggleberries all colorful ways
of saying balls and for those of us that
have balls we know that maintaining that
area down below can be a challenge
now for me stop me if you heard this one
before I work a lot of damn hours and
that means that sometimes I come on to
this show like today looking like I
jumped out of bed and was immediately
hit by a freight train now I'm gonna
pivot a little bit today because you
know we've talked about this already and
to be quite Frank the Family Jewels are
doing okay you know the lawnmower 4.0
has done its job so now we're going to
talk about
um
the area up here a little bit uh because
you know uh
since I haven't groomed okay
let's say I blow my nose or anything
like that it it kind of looks like I
have a hedgehog you know or an aardvark
living in my nose so
thankfully in addition to the lawnmower
4.0 we have the a weed whacker ear nose
and and and nose hair trimmer which is
uh fantastic so yeah uh I I had to I
have to take care of that so my
apologies for my appearance but again
you know it's it's exhibit a right you
can see that I need some help in that
situation so
let me talk about the performance
package 4.0 which has arrived and of
course it is a game changer inside this
package you'll find the lawnmower 4.0 as
I talked about trimmer the weird whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer which I've
talked about the crop preserver ball
deodorant the crop reviver toner
performance boxer briefs and a travel
bag to hold your goodies first off the
lawnmower 4.0 this trimmer is the future
of grooming and dare I say the greatest
ball trimmer ever I can concur uh it no
Nicks whatsoever I'm very happy the
fourth generation trimmer features a
Cutting Edge ceramic blade to reduce
grooming accidents thanks to their
Advanced Skin safe technology the
lawnmower 4.0 is waterproof and also has
4 000 LED spotlights so you need you
know when you need a more precise shave
so because this trimmer is waterproof
you can say goodbye to the mess on the
bathroom floor as well you can do it in
the shower if you want you thought that
was good but you want to take your
grooming game even further to the next
level the performance package 4.0 also
includes the weed whacker nose and ear
hair trimmer like I said uh have like a
porcupine living in my nose so the weed
whacker is also waterproof and provides
proprietary skin safe technology which
helps reduce Nicks snags and tugs in
those delicate nose holes then we have
the crop preserver ball deodorant and
crop reviver ball toner which will
change the way you approach your hygiene
routine trust me when I say this fellas
your balls will thank you
manscape was even kind enough to throw
in two free gifts into the performance
package 4.0 the manscape boxers and the
shed travel bag so you can bring your
comfort and your boxers to another level
so
if it's time to take care of yourself
you need to go to manscape.com and get
20 off and free shipping with code iron
Lords once again that's 20 off and free
shipping with the code iron Lords at
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com and use code
iron Lords unlock your confidence and
always use the right tools for the job
with manscaped know that joystick where
you at you missed your shot bro like
no no let's not do that bro this is your
time you said your man set it up for you
to get the Glizzy
companion yo it was wild out here it was
wild today we're going to focus on it it
took me everything to be my bike for me
because for me you know when I haven't
shaved right sometimes you forget and
it's like in my you know when you're
older it's funny because I used to laugh
with my dad when I was like damn pops it
was like hair coming out of these weird
places and now I'm not using your nose
now I'm that dude yeah I'm like I blew
my nose and it you see it yeah oh no no
yeah it was too much up in there yeah
the funniest thing is when I use that um
The manscape Joint yeah and I hit it
done first breath that you take that you
inhale and you're like oh my God oh my
God I can really breathe there and those
heads is crazy bro yeah no it says a
while so go put that in the chat uh we
have a little [__] for you yeah
absolutely uh we don't support products
that we're not using no we're using
these and this and like I said there was
no need to reiterate the the stuff for
the nether regions because bro it did
the job it did the job and shout out to
those um I ain't gonna front did y'all
use debrief [__] the music yeah
get your package together y'all just I'm
just saying protect the goods as well I
like I like the the ball wiping uh
respect
feeling good feeling good we used to
this as babies but you know as a grown
adults
swamp sack is real man
summertime it's crazy out here so yeah
go manscape.com use cool iron Lords go
get that support the realm you know what
I'm saying make sure I keep those Dusty
Master swords up out of here so we're
gonna continue
oh that'll break protocol
let's go let's play with each other's
joysticks five dollars SOB throw out
that lawnmower 4.0 I'll do your lips
make sure to go over everything whoa
he's back oh he's on Thomas he's on
perfect timing they even had to laugh at
themselves
we got a chance to really talk really
bill it is cool for brothers to get
together you know what I'm saying we
said some real stuff to be it I I'll
respect you for that bro cause you you
know we going through so salute to you
bro shout out to Danny Pena as well oh
the OG the part four the Pod father you
got a chance to break there's so many
people we gonna continue yeah
um so yeah so [__] I I guess we'll do
the next thing after the first after our
first uh topic so yeah no patreon no
poll we're gonna get right into it so um
yeah Xbox showcase the aftermath you
know what I'm saying and um you know got
a chance obviously it's good to be with
y'all all together you know obviously
you guys are here front lines holding it
down live reactions being clipped
everywhere me and addict out there in
the field in the actual building and you
know so it was a little different all of
us not being together but now that we're
uniting how we feeling you know I got a
couple questions for you like how are we
feeling now that the dust has settled
you know about to Showcase you I don't
know if you got a chance to look back at
it you know in its entirety and um I
think the other things I have is like
okay what you think could have been
improved or not improved and another
thing I kind of want to hit separately
is I want to hit Starfield direct
separately so let's just talk about the
Showcase outside of Starfield now that
the dust is settled how we feeling start
to look at it
of the overall showcase I thought it was
it was a solid show you know people
you could nitpick at all but I think for
the most part
Xbox did show look we're working on
these Studios these are what they're
doing I will say that in terms if you
still want proof that some of these
studios are delivering the type of
experiences or is the money that
Microsoft having going to actually
Elevate some of these these developers
that is still in the air but I will say
is like you see Starfield
a lot of the main production of that
game was done under Xbox so it's just
you know
2021 Starfield probably was going to
come out
but they gave them till 2022 and then
they gave them an additional like year
up until 2023
so you know you can make a lot of
assumptions you can go left or right
when it comes to a lot of things but you
can clearly see that Microsoft is
funneling money funneling talent and
more importantly funneling tie to these
Studios look at waistline three they put
a lot of different content in there that
wasn't going to be in the base game they
gave them time uh Psychonauts too the
majority of those bosses weren't in the
game if not any of those bosses in the
game but guess what because of the time
and money Microsoft was funneling
through that studio they gave they were
able to make the game better there's
been very few incidences where you can
argue to say that it's not been that way
across the board sure some studios You
could argue mismanagement but guess what
when you got 23 25 30 50 60 kids some
are they gonna reveal
as possible what games I get out we're
gonna keep starting direct separate One
games had you them excited the most
I will say Starfield fable
um that that Clockwork Clockwork
Revolution that looks really good too
I don't know why but that 33 game 33
Immortals that game would had to be
pretty hyped I actually might reach out
to them try to get a an interview on the
on the channel
yeah it's just like look
that's the best part about this sure
some games Resolute with me less than
others but I can't say nothing on that
show was less appealing than other stuff
sure there's stuff I was more excited
about but when you're looking at you
know they had solid experiences and
Charlotte showings of these games there
you know we talked about you know people
don't necessarily care if Indies are in
in in these Lord
they disagree here they they just the
latest people people generally want to
see Indies that are appealing to that
individual person and you know City
skylines too very popular game yeah it's
there that 33 game you know
interesting sure thought no but it's
interesting it's there
you know going to the PlayStation thing
they had three Indie Games dedicated to
cat game it's a cat
you know for the most part
Maybe
straight kicked off so well they backed
up the truck to some of these Indie
developers when they come to cat related
experiences it's like
Xbox did what they were what I wanted
them to do okay here's some of the and
what's funny is they did the 12-month
thing and they didn't say it yeah like
if you really think about a clock
besides clock yeah and Fable every game
coming out in 12 months yeah in a way
that is correct lasting from you um
anything that you would have improved
could have improved I'm sure you think
um I do think in the middle it started
drying out a little bit like
um it just got to the point where I I
think
that the biggest criticism I can give is
listen to the community there's no way
people that was in charge of that
particular showcase
thought showing hellblade without combat
was going to go over well for them to me
and maybe you guys disagree I feel like
it would have been better
to just not show help like that
interesting if they were going to show
another CG of the thing that we know
right the biggest thing we know about
hellblade is this gonna look good
and she's crazy yeah the psychosis is
real and guess what
that's all we still know
it's just that that's why that's one of
my good critiques I can give them
another big critique I can give them is
I know they did that star Phil direct
but I felt like it could have the pacing
could have a little bit different like
you know Phil should have came up there
said you know this is the show that we
want to give you guys blah blah blah
however he him and PR decide to spin it
but we have one more game to show you
before we get to the Starfield one and
then they show so clock uh Clockwork
Revolution
like I feel like this is that we we we
did pick it for Perfection right but I
know what you're saying right it's like
when we me you would have did it next to
each other the one more game ended up
becoming Starfield and we're going to
get into Starfield how amazing that was
which ended up being fine but me and you
both agree that if like clockwork
Revolution was so impressive they could
have laid that as the here's the last
one more game then you end with
Clockwork Revolution then you put the
timer up and they'll kick this thing
needs to be a long time like two minutes
and you got to think too we sat there
for an hour I think like an hour and 10
15 minutes or something like that
it would have been easy just to give
like a another five minute countdown
give people not trying to go use the
bathroom or something and then go into
the star or they could have just went
straight from that one more thing to
Starfield but I didn't like the fact
that they kind of got rid of the one
more thing because that's that's always
something that we look forward to
because they've done it with Fable
they've done it with redfall they've
done it with Starfield well not them
particularly Bethesda did it with
Starfield they might have did Elder
Scrolls I can't what about particularly
that year but they have done so many
yeah we got one more game for you and to
me they kind of like got rid of that
magic and all it could have been kept
intact if Phil just came out there and
said this is what we have to look
forward to but before we go and start
the Starfield direct we have one more
game to show I understand I understand
your nitpick I I I I definitely see
where you're coming from based on
tradition and maybe part of it was they
were just so excited that maybe they
knew they had something stuff feel that
it was just like we're going but I hear
where you're going from just get let's
get soft you know now the dust has
settled you know what you're feeling how
you feeling about the Showcase and then
what was the things you were most
excited for
I mean it's still a nine for me right
last week I was kind of hovering eight
or five eight point five nine and it's
definitely a nine for me um and I'm
difficult to please when it comes yes to
them right yeah we're solidified this
it's just the fact that they did exactly
what I needed them to do wanted them to
do was just show me first party stuff
that you've talked about already right
we saw some stuff that we kind of
because of because of our proximity to
the industry we you know certain things
leak and things like that and and you
kind of have an idea certain things like
coming but sometimes that comes to
fruition sometimes it doesn't right so
for me the thing that that popped crazy
was
Sega in the building
um
come on I say it as a joke
I want it to happen it's just it's
traditionally not been a thing that and
which is funny because again we always
saw Xbox as the surrogate Sega right and
for whatever reason obviously we saw
what happened during the Xbox one
generation that relationship seemed like
it distanced and then now it's being
reforged again and to see the presence
there with not only the new like a
dragon right and ichiban's
bunotized
out here showing his buns
um but to show Persona 3 remake for the
first time on this stage to show tactics
for the first time on the stage and then
to announce a new IP from the creators
of persona on this stage is huge it is
huge because it's foreshadowing sir
but I'm not giving that up as someone
King who that was the line into the very
last time
I I gotta I Gotta Throw My Little
needles into it do not begrudge me I
love what you're doing I love I respect
it I respect the song the very last day
I got it I gotta say it ain't looking
good for me
it is only it is only if my man Jim Ryan
I had the foresight to have the
exclusive bag before the release
so I don't know if that happened but
this is a good look this is a good look
this is Xbox needed this and to see that
love
um I think you know if Sega is going to
go to anybody I would love to see them
with Xbox if that's gonna happen at all
they ain't going to nobody they damn
sure ain't going to uh Sony
I'm not going to my killers
let me see what else what else impressed
me obviously seeing Fable for the first
time I was like I just had I saw it I
was like all addict oh they're all added
I've never felt happier yeah with
someone else what's up bro let me tell
you king
he scared me out of scared because we're
in the theater you don't know but he
didn't react so he's just gonna see that
he's just Frozen watching so and my mom
like he's so critical and this is
beloved if he don't and I'm sitting
there remember I'm the Fable casual you
like it I'm not as hardcore as him with
it I played it I remember it but I was
born the Halo and other things during
the OG days of watching but I didn't
like it because the level of fun yeah
so I'm looking at it and I'm like okay
this looked really
yeah and I'm looking at him and then he
ain't saying nothing so I tap him and
I'm like we good like you know this is
his baby he's like oh no we good
I said Atticus please
continue he was just in such shock yeah
but they they nailed they nailed the
tone they nailed the comedy they nailed
what I would I would love to see from
the combat right just in seeing those
parts don't know how much gameplay that
actually is so that is an engine and
that is can very easily be gameplay
um I just love where it seems like they
have a a really really good idea of what
they want to do with this IPM make it
their own while still having reverence
for the tone of it and what it was in
the past right and it's a fine line to
draw it's difficult you think about you
know Studios that have taken over IP
look at the 343s or whatever it's not
easy to do yeah
um so and for them their first time out
yeah they they're tasked with rebooting
the whole damn thing that's a huge
responsibility it's a huge
responsibility I think so far so good
everything looks great real quick did
they say 2024 yeah tell me yeah they
didn't say 20 24 I thought they did it
mattered it was nothing but I could have
solved did you see it it is so
impressive looking that you have people
questioning whether or not they had
comment and gameplay in it and you got
the devs responding on Twitter with the
time when she threw the Fireball and
when they did the sword class because
they what they did is they clipped it in
really quick it was like a quick flag
exactly throw the Fireball and so it all
looked very cinematic right so they were
like it is the ultimate flattery for us
when people tell us this is not gameplay
like I built the car back he put the
clip up I was like yo that is impressive
I started to interrupt but I did want to
say that so that um and we'll talk about
starfish so beyond that obviously
um Clockwork
um Revolution clock Revolution
um I I was one of the first ones I think
I'll write on the show a lot I was like
yeah it has some Bioshock energy and I
was like okay and I didn't realize how
close to that Bioshock uh infinite sort
of trailer that was the trailer and the
funny thing is that trailer a lot of
stuff in that trailer the Bioshock one
ultimately did not come to the game in
that form right it wasn't that so they
they kind of idea wise they were kind of
on the same wavelength but the the
moment-to-moment gameplay of what what
this game is supposed to be is going to
be very distinct from what Bioshock is
first of all it's still an RPG right so
they're gonna stick to their roots and
that but there's an RPG with the
Fidelity of a third person sort of but
Bethesda Style game
um I am super interested to see how they
pull this off the time mechanic seems uh
something super interesting again I'm
interested to see how they pull that off
in game but I like the fact that annexal
is getting that shine
you know because sometimes no matter how
great the games that they make if they
make a certain type of game and in a
certain pocket and with for them you
know the isometric RPG kind of crpg
style of game they may be great you're
not going to get as many eyes on it with
this you're going to get the eyes on it
it's going to allow people to see how
great they are right and then gravitate
to their other stuff so I love that and
and finally gotta interrupt one more
time
um in it gotta shout both of y'all out
that way that was holding it down for us
in Exile tweeted IOP they love you and
King's reaction to how impressed you
were so to see them showing they're very
active on social media and I agree to
see them show out with a budget and they
wait like they were looking to see how
people
um received it so shout out to y'all
because they however y'all reacted when
that came up they were like shout out
the IOP like they they lived for that
because they were really proud of you
could tell what they what they put out
but continues up yeah and finally about
there was all the quick things like I I
like seeing Star Wars there but we'll
talk about that in the context of
Ubisoft
um obviously Capcom showing out what a
brand new IP was awesome too
um they kind of I thought it was Oni
Musha at first and then it wasn't it was
definitely a great fake out and the fact
again brand new IP from Capcom being
showcased coming to Game Pass day one
right fantastic but for me and this one
this one I I was surprised to the wreath
some of the reaction online was the
vowed because I was I saw that route I
was like yes let's go and then
afterwards when I heard it was like it's
a smaller game and it's it's not trying
to be skyrimeskin scope yeah like I'm
I'm Gucci he's been asking for it oh
they said we gonna do us we're not gonna
try we do what we do this is the thing
about it right and and this is and I'll
go quickly into one of my worries still
for for Starfield is that the stuff that
is the stuff that it it is sort of
pre-canned and stuff like that again are
we gonna have that wide ocean two inches
deep when it comes to depth of gameplay
and no specific scenarios right not the
not the crafted scenarios but the other
stuff right
why would you want them to make an
entire game mimicking that when their
thing is depth of Storytelling
characters tightly knit story have them
just keep doing that in different worlds
infinite possibilities with the story
where you could completely change the
outcome of of stuff because of that yeah
absolutely exactly and to to do a story
in the pillars World which is already
very lore rich and to do us another
story in that world that that kind of
removes you from the previous two
pillars games I think it's great I think
this is what they do best they take
formulas and they can kind of parse it
down into something smaller that is a
lot more detailed than for me personally
as somebody who wants more of that in my
next gen games where worlds feel more
alive character interactions feel more
lively they're better positioned to do
something like that in a smaller scope
game so I'm excited for a Vibe I'm
excited for what I saw I don't need it
to be Skyrim part two I don't need it to
be that so overall they got that nine
for me man they really did it I get my
only not gripe yeah would be the same as
what everybody else yeah I didn't need
to see help with it again if you didn't
show me that fight because you know
listen they they need to up for it to
really have that hashtag one uh just one
sort of standing it needs to improve on
that moment to moment yes uh Combat
gameplay because it the inevitable sort
of comparisons are going to be made to
other games in that band especially with
this game looking as good as it does
right and narratively being as strong as
we expect it to be so we we need that
right so I hope we get that the game
awards or something like that or maybe
even Gamescom who knows
um so that and then the one more thing
thing yes also I said
what and This Is Me Being Greedy yeah
this is striving for Perfection right
yeah I just one more thing because we
already knew you're gonna give us an
hour of Starfield give us just and it
does it it could be five years out six I
don't care just give me a logo so people
go crazy and crying and whatever and I
would have really been the icing on the
cake but again they were fine they were
fine
um very impressed with this now now the
hard part execution execution absolutely
that's it absolutely King you are the
hold the line movement you know you were
in the you know you were in live in the
mix so now that the dust is settled you
know we'll get to start for later but
like how we feeling about the Showcase
you know how's he feeling about what was
the games that had you most excited
specifically um we have a thousand
people watching oh you know 500 likes oh
we're getting these likes up get these
likes up get the likes the only reason
why I'm asking you for the likes and and
likes I hope it doesn't take anything
from you I hope when you push the like
button you don't lose no like that don't
happen to you yeah I think and and I
think this is true that when you hit the
like button you save the uh Puerto Rican
platypuses
all the Platypus around the world
that's bad escapes job we're gonna save
the African platypus when you share it
out but um let's let's let's do that
because it helps us in algorithm thanks
um and I'm just learning about it
all right so the last Xbox show we was
like oh that's the great best format
that they got they need to keep that yes
they listen yeah
I believe this is intermax
I believe Aaron Greenberg and the
marketing team is the best at dealing
with fan of fan contact
on the ground
his team has no equal
right not even Bethesda with their
Bethesda shows has that level of contact
with their with their fan base the way
that they do that the way that Microsoft
implements it is
um so intimate
so casual
so family oriented that is hard to
quantify right uh and Bethesda would do
a show their shows were
like Ringling Brothers and balling belly
circus it was the greatest show on Earth
not bad but there's a show so because I
got a question to you right being that
she was at Fan Fest this year yes and I
thought it was going to be in his
limited capacity did you feel that they
put on the greatest showman kept it
still family friendly close contact uh
emergency did you feel that energy they
did that that was a great one because
again for the people the initial fear
was always just going to be we're in the
theater and that's it but there was
things behind the scenes you guys didn't
see where people came out the executive
leadership booty came out it talked
about you know the pipeline stuff they
learning from you know what I'm saying
the the refwork situation I was
surprised that kind of came up in a way
you know Sarah Bond comes out she talks
about the strides and where they're
making and improving you know what I'm
saying as far as you know Japanese games
and things of that nature you know
greeny with the community getting them
getting everybody problems obviously
hold the line and all that stuff but to
see the excitement it was an energy
right that it's like it wasn't none of
this temper your expectation type of
energy it was yo we got something right
and we're gonna hold y'all down for
holding us down and then Phil I got to
get Phil credit the dominant some credit
he did something in my opinion that was
that was real man talk in the sense that
he's like look I'm an emotional guy kind
of wearing my heart on my sleeves
sometimes and it was like a indirect
reference to the kind of funny interview
right he's like say sometimes I may say
things out of emotion but it's kind of
uh indicative of what he talked about
Pride which was like I could see it but
it doesn't go mad until y'all see it
right and now that we see it and then
they're seeing the blessing and
reception of it you can see it's
different but yeah to your point being
there in the building as well as The Fan
Fest to your point you know they were it
was it was a movie I mean it was
complete fan service and then afterwards
you know they had to set up and and they
were what's the word like accessible you
could yeah and you could reach out to
them like everyone's there in them it's
a celebrate you know you don't revive
you it's a celebration yeah you remember
remember that Jake that Matrix part one
got clowned and it was the um
the only reason why I said that right
because um that was my perception of it
and this was this was always my hope
that they learned the Showmanship of
xenomax and they incorporate the family
feel of Xbox yeah and then translate it
over to the show so we thought that last
year's show was the best pacing and this
year they continued that same pacing and
I and I respected like the after shows
shout out to Paris and the teams
um and Microsoft uh proper show the
proper show
I'm gonna get into what I didn't like
yeah let's go what I didn't like was
y'all guys don't understand what uh um
the the plus one the the and his one
more here's one more thing understand
what that means all right it doesn't
mean show me the same knife that you had
here
it was exciting you know what they had
the Bazooka and Tuck they was ready yeah
yeah but you don't that's not you don't
show hayachi hat and go
and
that's not that's not the plus one okay
that's that's just not it you failed
miserably when it came to that we
already knew Starfield was going to be
there so it wasn't a ah and we got one
more thing we knew well don't do that
again so let me back you up what about
Starfield having a clip in the jointed
would you oh we're gonna get to that too
okay let me get your balls let me get
your boss right it's just
I'm gonna start where where you was
wrong oh okay okay you could have and
and don't do the Clockwork thing there
because
I'll explain as as well show us
the distance
show us the Hail Mary the down the block
all right show us something that you
have in Tuck that is
known no don't do Clockwork there
because Clockwork was needed where it
was at but because they started getting
a low no don't do the Clockwork there
damn disrespected do something else you
could just throw something else I don't
care what it was but the Hail Mary that
was there okay um the other the other uh
stub your toe
was Forza hmm
um I personally
wanted to see
that killer
and what I got was
yeah we Forza we here
um we know what we do but
um that wasn't it like wow I I wanted to
because I'm used to turn 10 showing up
being turned 10. right and I know I know
when the game comes out if this is what
happens when you have separate little
cons and stuff like that and it's forces
so big that they save a lot of that
stuff for their Forza special events
okay and yeah that that kind of took
away from this because I wanted this to
show I want remember the first time we
saw Falls and we saw the ray tracing it
was awesome it was doing all this stuff
and people was walking around show me
that okay show me that so and then you
had the um the hell blade yeah did have
gameplay now let me tell you I mean
didn't have the fighting Combat gameplay
that these guys wanted
the first time we saw it I don't think
that was run on an Xbox series X okay
yeah I think that was run on a dev kit
or a PC okay this one was on a series oh
it made it very clear yes right and I
think that's
we're we're confusing what we want and
what they are uh showing the first one
wasn't really all that real it was real
but it wasn't really all that real this
one is representative exactly what
you're gonna get okay so here we're
gonna throw that in there and they're
gonna make it and in the back they're
like you love it yeah we say series X
they run right but
we thought that's what it looked like
over here the first time right you know
what I'm saying so we know that over
here with some type of sleight of hand
here you showing the actual hand wait we
thought it was actual hand the first
time I understand where we at with it
next time we see it we'll see game uh
the combat we'll see all of that I I
believe that but that's the stubborn of
the tote okay
um pacing of the show you had to show
your games of service that was great you
did all of that you had to show
everything that was going inside Game
Pass you had to show all your third
party deals that was there that was
great the pacing of the show was
fantastic
um uh and the hardware oh yeah the
hardware was brief it was it was to the
point and it was there some idiot online
said Microsoft if you were able to share
the the series X we went to everybody at
the same price releasing it now the the
ssds didn't cost that price before
so now that they're able to they they
lower the cost on ssds you're able to
put a one terabyte in there now and we
can sell it for the same price that we
selled it before that's that's how
business works trust me if they was able
to put one terabyte in back then and not
get beat all around the legs because of
the the series s had the smaller um SSD
size and wasn't able to have as much
stuff in there they would they would
have never took that L then so it just
didn't make any sense but the hardware
yes little man we know now is the money
maker for them
series X like Phil came out and said the
pipeline is opened up so you start
seeing more series x's in the store and
it'll be uh easier for you to purchase
uh what because the reason why I was so
high on Forza because that was my game
that I really wanted to see the most I
feel you but let me can I push back a
little bit in the sense that you're
right historically Forza has gotten no
segments right right where it's the Deep
dive you see the power you see that why
they one of the kings of racing and you
notice the mainline Motorsport right the
the graphical showcase what about
because I'm seeing the energy that
people are like yo we happy this the
first Xbox show with the future is so
bright with the other Studios with the
2018 draft class right and now we ain't
even gotta rely on them the Big Mac
large fries in the shake of Halo games
what about that new day energy I just
wanted to know okay is it everything
that I'm hearing is it a game of service
game now where we're going to be having
seasons and all this real stuff like
that's what I wanted to know right
um how how are you going to because you
know Forza Horizon is great and all that
stuff but there's a distinct facts
separation between the two uh racing
titles right you know you have the
hardcore gritty dudes like um my
cousin-in-law Oliver he put monitors
together he got like three four monitors
and he has a steering wheel he does that
he's asking me about it and I was like
yo they really didn't say anything new
and and I was able to talk to him about
it a little bit but um that's what I
wanted for you and then uh
the bigger titles for me let's go what
was the ones you're excited about
um 33 Immortals yes
I said wow like the cloud is really out
here now right because now you're using
to offload uh uh bandwidth and stuff
like that this this stuff is really
going to hit different when we get a
chance to play it a vow I didn't want a
vow to be uh the size of Skyrim or all
that stuff I I really wanted to be like
an out of Worlds uh something tight
something you know just just a real good
RPG with branching stories and but told
in a kings-filled manner I want
kingsfield modern day and that's what
they showed me I saw people were talking
about it was a downgrade and Graphics no
this is what you saw was a CGI trailer
before and now you saw uh actual game uh
graphic so how can you downgrade from a
CGI it's just idiotic stuff for people
to to nitpick I gave this the show a 9.5
I think I've argued about a vow too many
times I'm gonna let that slip yeah you
gonna let it go yeah
are you on the side of it oh you're
disappointed just real quick I just need
to know I didn't know
I'm not on the side of a downgrade
I'm on the side that I feel like they
didn't properly keep our expectations in
check from the CGI they showed us the
first time okay so you bought it because
when you see when you see the CGI from
the first trailer it kind of seemed more
you know
more of a serious tone art style but
then when you see that it does look a
little bit more like that colorful that
that of uh that the outer worlds doing
and and even with that even with my
disappointment to a degree with that I
still think this game's gonna be as far
as like review Wise It's still gonna get
like an 80 89 90 91 92 it's still going
to do extremely well but I personally
had a different tone of art that I
thought about was going to look like and
then when I saw the game it didn't meet
the expectations they set when they
showed me that first trailer interesting
okay
so
it's just
everything that they showed I'm super
excited for about the most 33 in the
Capcom game uh
I didn't expect it
um this is something that I definitely
can't wait to play and then you know of
course there's Starfield yeah we're
gonna continue but um those are the
games that I'm looking for the most the
show was a fantastic pace and I thought
Microsoft hit it out the part I and I
just like the fact that they respected
us as The Gaming Community yes uh it's
sometimes we laugh when we joke and it's
a console war crap and you know hold the
line or whatever the hell
um
and I know that everybody says you know
we bootleg um corporations
I hear you dudes right and I and I hear
everything that you guys are saying
and I know you're gonna say well they
they don't owe us anything they just
need to make good games and I just
support good games shut up
shut up you
somebody that you hand your money over
there smack you in the face with a good
game wow man take your game and get her
out of here oh they smacked me but they
gave me a good game
stop that right
um you want to have some respect some
Rapport going through and I know you're
probably saying that Microsoft is doing
this because they're in third place
let's see what happens when they're in
first place
that will be happening soon
right very very soon so much that you
can see it I can see it we both know it
I honestly believe with this level of
management that's in place and I'm
seeing it from the top down to the
bottom
they will operate the same way when
they're in first place
and it will be the same report that you
do have so I'm just happy that gaming as
a whole Microsoft did exactly what I
hope they did save gaming that week okay
not fair enough fair enough y'all pretty
much knocked out all the points I wanted
to say so as far as my feeling is just
that like you said the um I just feel
like the the energy from um executive
leadership the way they presented was
tremendous I think they've really solved
the problem as far as you know showcase
presentation pacing game the game the
game they didn't do the couches all that
Joy you know what I'm saying that was
fully extended they they've got their
pocket and I also with the direct I feel
you know gave that more in-depth you
know path to really showcasing which
we'll get into um as far as the games
obviously Fable for me was mind-blowing
if playground pulls this off
the the level of production value the
graph the graphical Fidelity is so good
it has people questioning and that that
is something to really to really come in
you know I thought that was phenomenal I
thought NX look in Excel we've been told
we told people for a long time they've
been sleeping and cooking and you know
that is a super talented team that is
the creators of Fallout that is you know
Wasteland three one of the greatest turn
based games going storyline Divergent
like they are so ambitious I love your
man who's too bougie Lord crawling and
you got the he got the thing with you
the peasants he will not walk amongst
the common folk and he'll be he's not
touching that that peasant ground no
when I saw that I said yeah this is
so-called yeah it felt so Silver Surfer
yes he says gold yes my feet will not be
touching the ground you know the
Ambitions of the time travel that that
was amazing you know I agree with
everybody you want to vow you know to
see a
obsidian stay in their pocket and say we
are not trying to cop we're gonna do
what we do best I do push back on attic
with the um tone thing I think this is
my feeling they still showed dark biomes
they were still dark things so I think
that they're just showing a diversity in
biomes I saw a desert area I didn't look
at it now if they would have came out
and he's slashing clowns and it's he and
then I'm like okay it's colorful it's a
different tone I saw magic to the level
let's be real and I'm an Elder Scrolls
Star Wars guy I mean star Starfield kind
of guy but like we got to be clear when
you play Oblivion and Skyrim you shoot
the magic and it's pure and it's just a
single little like they're doing
singularities like Mass Effect with the
with the enemies floating in the air you
controlling the thing then they got the
standard you know they got the double
barrel they got that sword and shield
you can do care with the knife in the
shield
it reminded me of um damn Mass Effect
like um like biotics yes
and you doing this on next gen check
with all these characters floating the
air controlling it then they had to boot
a Sparta this is Sparta kick to Detroit
you beheading people like come on like I
get it people may you know just wanted
to have this one type of biome and all
that is going to be down in the dungeons
with the skeletons enemies I take that
but yeah like bro like to me it was
still showing that energy in addition to
other Lush areas I have no problem with
it so that's just me but again I'm
biased I love the city and they've been
holding it down and as far as I'm
concerned they've had Xbox on their back
during the series console generation and
no one can you say what you want because
I even I was a hater or a a skeptic of
grounded in the beginning when you play
them games they are quality games so
salute to them 33 Immortals I agree uh
solve them with you on the atlas I'm
showing the um you know the IPS the
Persona tactics I thought that looked
cool
um
you know what no one's talking about
low-key I know I'm probably gonna pop it
in and then uninstall it because the
hard drive space Microsoft flights the
rescue thing they had a fire rescue
ambulance this like it has so many it
was a new game right yeah well it has so
many modes I'm like that's kind of
interesting like I didn't go front like
and it's a sobos of [__] like they've
shown out you see what they could do
they almost like to do the Doom yeah
it's kind of crazy and then they have
something like that that was like combat
almost like like dog fighting no you saw
the
um the the aerial is uh yeah yeah aerial
joint so I've been salute to them for
the support like King said live service
they're gonna still support see if they
have to Monkey Island is a big deal
that's a big deal that's a big deal I
thought I said they said but but
according to something you know what
even even Fallout 76.
come on don't let's not lie right people
when they told us to buy the joint and
they didn't tell us anything because
they have no service to throw it in
because we've been highly skeptical of
what Todd was asking and then it came in
the state that it did yes but for it to
be inside Game Pass of course and for
them to say yo we keep throwing stuff in
there we're gonna keep fixing it yeah it
it works yeah for that Community they
get content
for that for them for those guys but
look you know I personally want us
Fallout New Vegas remake or Fallout 4
that's just me you know what I'm saying
but um oh yeah now we ain't disrespected
Tyler born we're gonna get that was that
was really cool I like the climbing
little indie game the attic like I
forgot the name of it are you talking
about the um
yeah yo stop it you're doing that and
then uh I'm just saying that game of the
year but solve is Right yo path of the
Goddess where he got the Shaolin thing
he's protected a little negation did you
see you see the Wang Chung
martial arts sensibilities and know that
for a new IP big deal anyway let's get
to the main event because you know what
we had I want to uh respect um Alex
Thomas I got to get his balls on this
too
um
let's get to this direct real quick with
Starfield you know um I'm gonna just
jump off
you know we gotta we gotta really be
respectful you know of God Howard here
you know he got a lot of Arrow slung at
him you know the bug that's the we
talked about listen think about the
pressure they have had coming into this
game yep where this game has to save
Xbox
this game if it's not this Xbox is out
of here
um it's just so much you know and then
obviously 76 which is Bethesda Austin
right a separate team but they still
carrying the slings of that but what it
goes to show me you know even with the
referral situate all that stuff that's
not them
for them to show out the way they did it
under this amount of pressure
and not only meet expectation
exceed expectation to the point I'm
Gonna Keep it above being ran I think
talk about this
you can make the argument this is the
greatest Showcase of a game
in gaming conference history you can
make the art like you can't walk away
from this and say I don't know what
Starfield is remember that talk with the
dude you're capping they don't even know
which star field is right now the only
thing you can tell me is you like Cog I
don't like the Western RPGs I don't do
that kind of game fine if you say that
fine I ain't gonna push back but if you
gonna walk away and tell me one to one
what game is doing exactly this I
challenge there is none there is none
the scope is insane so it's like this
was really a Shining Moment for that
team you know I got a chance to talk to
Todd and Pete pre-show and the energy
was kind of like you know we just hope
we you know we're getting excited you
know we hope you guys like what we have
to offer but I would tell you Ken
talking to them after and seeing how it
was received and people Blown Away with
the possibilities that they could do
they were literally like it was like
proud dad like you know we are so happy
you know be hot telling me all the
things you can do about boarding people
[__] and raid and stuff and doing stuff
all the things that the algorithm would
create the engine and here's the other
thing I want to do because I do see this
disingenuous you know we're gonna get to
the frames talk I'm not gonna avoid that
right and yes Cog would love it to be 60
and yes I was disappointed initially
when we heard the 30 right I'm not gonna
say I'm not you know so of course we
don't want that but here's the thing and
this is where a lot of people with these
disingenuous oh well because Horizon is
60 frames per second and oh because this
is 60 frames bro that's not even the
same Stratosphere when you play a game
where you kill someone and their bodies
remain there when you play a game and
everything in the game is interactable
and I've got to call I love Final
Fantasy but let's be clear at it you
know when you play Final Fantasy the
remix whatever whatever the game puts a
shining light on the only interactable
thing you can touch in the world you you
can't go in every house you can't kill
every NPC you can't do anything those
are static because they're sacrificing
the gameplay and the complexity of the
systems for the graphical Fidelity that
is a game design choice that is so for
people to sit there now you want to say
hey these models ain't looking as sharp
as whatever okay fine but name the game
that's doing what they're doing the
things that stood out for me like I said
the melee combat was crazy running down
on dudes punching them doing all that
type of stuff you know I felt like the
the skill tree system was at the
procedural generation we know about the
Gunplay much improved you know what I'm
saying the jet packing moving around way
way improve you know it became a point
it was like what can't this game do
like what literally like what can you
can play it how you truly want to play
it so I think the issue comes down to
yes you as far as afraid you can be
disappointed that you're not 60 but if
if it comes down to limiting the scope
of this game so that you can't interact
with everything for the 60 I ain't gonna
lie like there's a PC for you to take it
to where you want to take it to but I'm
on the side of innovation and doing
things I've never seen before in gaming
so in that respect this is where tears
of the kingdom does come in in that
respect game players okay here's the
last part I know I'm going along
what's funny about Twitter and social
media it is truly an echo chamber
because you know why for the people who
are like this is an embarrassment and
fair you want to say Xbox touted power
fair right and and this is this okay
fair
do you see what these pre-orders are
doing
do you see what these Zeitgeist is doing
it's the same like how tears of the
kingdom was people I know people who are
the most detractors of Starfield said
you know
was in a crew I got people who were like
yo I'm literally buying an Xbox for this
game like of course they gotta execute
you know myself but I'm finished blow V8
I had to get because my thing was I
heard a lot of talk
you know and and not respecting God
Howard's name as if he don't got his
face his games ain't on Mount Rushmore
as if Morrowind Skyrim Oblivion Fallout
are not on Mount Rushmore like that
games of the general we're not doing
that so for people who had that yo
respect this is the track record that we
respected and now y'all getting to see a
glimpse of of course they got to execute
of course we got to make sure it's not
technically broken but we are not going
to disrespect Legends in the game for
some Fanboy foolishness we're not doing
that and it's beautiful to see them reap
the rewards and the reception of what
this game is attempting to do okay I'm
done I got my random I had to get that
I've been holding that because don't let
don't let this game be no 90 something I
will be messy and I remember all the
tweets and all the comments I'm coming
for all of y'all cause y'all was talking
real Reckless to Legends in the game
period we're gonna respect our Legends
that's the last thing I'm gonna say okay
now I'm finished sorry
uh here here's how I feel about it
I'm playing on PC
um you know I'll have access to both so
you know I'll jump in and out to see if
it's even playable on the Xbox uh I
don't even think it's just a star for
this the issue it's the fact that we
were pretty much kind of like sold a
console that you know 60 frames is gonna
be the standard 120 is going to be the
it's going to be the exceptions or and
back to back to the AAA products there
have are coming out 30 frames you know I
can I don't think it would be as bad
people would still complain but it's the
fact that red fault and Starfish were
both 30 frames that is what's making it
look spooky and it's like when you come
out there and you make ultimate
decisions like that Aaron people are
going to check you later when it's stuck
when games start missing the the Target
and uh that's pretty much as far as that
goes I I will be playing Starfield on PC
and Xbox uh just depending on what's
going on at the time but
for the people that's generally upset
because it doesn't run 60. I feel you
for the people that's just using it to
get some traction to their Channel
go somewhere else with that
what about the game itself sir oh I mean
the gay games games fire you here's the
thing I've always said from the start
you know you can argue that Final
Fantasy not Final Fantasy you can argue
that
Todd Howard and Bethesda
together have a better track record of
the Naughty Dog uh so you know
I mean it's the truth
but here's the thing here's the thing
naughty dog has made defining games they
they've catapulted a lot of things
forward
Bethesda pretty much
catapulted the RPG genre every time
they've made a game two or three tiles
sure you you can you can give them
Fallout 76 even though they didn't make
that game it was a sister Studio that
made that game you can make that
argument and then you know Bethesda will
get that smoke just because Bethesda got
that smoke because their name is on the
on the box but Skyrim showed like what
80 million units they'll sell the Skyrim
to this day so crazy uh Oblivion
Morrowind Fallout three they didn't make
Fallout New Vegas even Fallout 4 which
is in my opinion the worst Fallout of
the bethesda's type of games
still was almost Game of the Year facts
it was a nomination for Game of the Year
and people want to sit there and they
look at Fallout 4 and they look at as a
negative notation even though I feel
like it's the worst Fallout
things still look at 86. that was the
end considered the three yeah so it's
like look fall Fallout 4 I do feel like
was that Trend downwards and and 76
didn't help help the matter but we can't
deny what they've done in the past
Bethesda has made some of the most
beloved games in gaming history
soundtrack to the streets period
period says Morrowind organic when it
comes to Starfield
it just
can they can they deliver what they say
you know fair for all we know they just
they could have just showed us the the
highlights the game and then we play it
and a lot of the systems don't work the
way they demonstrate it but it works is
that the way that it works that's fair
at the end of the day
I do feel like Xbox has showed that you
can give faith in it
but it's one of those things where I
always say trust and verify don't just
try no doubt fair enough fair enough
fair enough no doubt no doubt
um solve you know now it's got a chance
to marinate I I haven't really talked to
you too much about it you know Starfield
where you at with this directive
software
um we I was impressed I was very very
impressed and again for me my thoughts
going in is like I just worried what I
worried about is that you know Todd's
ambition and trying to make this vast
world would sort of leave
the stuff that I want to see more more
depth and like character and story and
like more density in in in cities and
things like that I was like well if he's
going for that something's going to
suffer and that's going to be it so I
was worried about that now I'm watching
this and just this entire breakdown of
what this game finally is
he's basically telling you this game is
the culmination of everything that we've
ever tried to implement in the Bethesda
game we're going to put into this game
right and it's probably going to be the
most polished version of all of those
implementations and it's going to be in
this game so in a lot of ways to this
point this is the magnum opus this is
everything that we've learned everything
that we've implemented everything that
we've heard you when it comes to what
the fans want we're going to try to put
into this game and what better game to
try to do that with than a vast SpaceX
Adventure when you're aesthetically
trying to to create space
um
and I think everything they talked about
here just kind of It kind of blew me
away the ambition right I'm still a
little bit you know and I say worried in
quotations I'm still a little bit
worried about the procedural generated
stuff and and how it's because for me
I'm an idiot I I know full well I should
not be playing these games this way
because I don't have the time to right
like I should be the dude that goes in
and goes from Story Mission to store
permission story spent I should be that
I should be the dude that's like oh yo
30 hours whatever the main campaign is
do that and be done with it no the first
thing I do is okay where am I supposed
to go no I'm going the other direction
squirrel what's that right in the
distance what's that right so I know I'm
going to encounter that uh other
procedural generated stuff that may not
be you know they did not have the the
depth that the other stuff has so my
thing is just that it doesn't feel
repetitive and say me like if you go to
a planet or something like that that
there's only a couple of things to do
that it's something new it's a store
everything or whatever the case may be
like I just want that
I was gonna say when it comes to like
the procedure generated stuff let's be
right here they only had like six seven
planets because it's Story related and
nothing else was there people say that
game doesn't feel like you're you're the
universe like you're traveling like as
long as like the core gameplay is isn't
procedurally generated like when it
comes to like the bigger cities because
I don't think there will be some of the
planets that's direct Story related and
then when it comes to like getting your
resources maybe uh farming certain
things that stuff is simulated I don't
think people are gonna have an issue
with that I think people are reading too
much into that yeah again but it is
something that again when you think
about the thing the aspects of the game
that are going to be created story wise
the the sort of the cities that are
supposed to be super dense and populated
and have all this stuff you know if you
see something that doesn't have that
level of detail in it it'll be a little
bit disappointing but again you got to
take that in context when you think
about the scope of the entire game so I
super like really really really
impressed
um and they they went all out you know
with the special editions with the with
the headset the controller so they
they're doing for this game what they're
supposed to to get the word out there
and again the proof is in the pudding
when it comes to yeah you can wait for
it in Game Pass there's a lot of people
that aren't waiting for it in Game Pass
yeah yeah it was funny I was talking I
was talking the attic that I talked to a
cog yesterday because I was like yo
y'all know that the Early Access for
this game starts when we're in we'll be
in Washington
I'm a gay pass being locally downloaded
look at this guy shout out to the wrong
Ally
so this is the thing I was like damn yo
I know y'all gonna be want to sit there
blazing we're gonna have to be working
the show floor and go to the series that
can go into hotel rooms very yeah
very easily yeah yeah but shout out to
us being at work yeah yeah exactly we'll
be too tired to do anything yo we gonna
stop acting like we we finish these
shows and we get back to them get back
and we doing stuff yeah let's game
to eat and go to sleep we got a new plan
shout out shout out to luck we got a new
plan baby things will be a little I
don't think so all right listen listen
you know how my legs feel after this
shout out to little man who will make
the trip with the Lord yeah might be a
little black man yeah
hey yo
okay
the First with the black and white
I got a little white man um
racial connotations on series
they should have had him on the piano
yeah for real I was I was impressed I'm
excited more now for the game than I
have been
um because again we finally got the
explanation of what it is and what it is
it really is is saying hey everything
that I've learned from working on these
games for God knows how long I'm gonna
try to implement into this game and try
to give you the most vast and still
detailed experience possible while
giving you the freedom to just do what
you want to do like I I can't imagine
how many penis spaceships we're gonna
see
it's gonna happen yeah
pull it up to me with the phallus but
that's the crazy thing right all of that
stuff could be in there and then when
you think about you know creation engine
and the mods and stuff like that and
where that's going to go and then
they're already talking about you know
additional content and DLC already so it
is it is a bgs Studios release in every
way shape and form it is it is bubbling
up to that oh this is one of those and
this is a moment in time
um and I and I'm excited oh so why he
said yo the black one got the bigger SSD
best
time well done well done
wow wow y'all really doing this
these stereotypes alone y'all gotta stop
I gotta stop
well done wow I like that I might have
to get a new little logo
no continue song we are not doing it
so I'm I'm excited because this is one
of those that's gonna be it's gonna be a
moment it's gonna be a moment and it's
hard to get moments like that anymore
man I mean because we don't have we
don't have like midnight releases and
things like that anymore like that
doesn't happen as much so the moments in
time like this are different right
they're not the same as they used to be
so yeah but they they did it man they
did it what else did it take derail in
the show
what's up
so Xbox believes in diverse expansive
packages
Robert Kelly good well done yeah
ridiculous man yeah solid state can't
take y'all seriously in a romance oh we
can have a serious conversation in the
room ever
the bbhd oh
it's you it's going down okay get your
balls up and then I do one because I
hadn't got a leader I want to get his
final fantasy topic before he leaves so
let's get your balls off a star field
because you you were the person I felt
the hardest to please I want to know
um
I I I'm happy for Todd
Todd ready the game when it came out
last year and it would have came out to
uh chorus of criticism mixed with
adulation
and I think now
most of the criticism will you know get
smaller with Wayne Uh from the extra
polish
there's no one that can say that they
can compare both presentations and don't
see
this time has benefited Todd graphically
and and you know let's just move away
from the 30 frames yeah versus 60 frames
um graphically this game
took a bump up yes
yes
um
and it I don't see certain things that I
was seeing before I went back and
watched the other one and I'm watching
it so I'm like okay this is a truly a
benefit to him
and and I think if this is just seminal
this is your Apex this is your climax
um to say
he is stamping his name now before he
was hoping that his games would be a
game of the year before he was uh in the
running for making a game that can be uh
a pillar and has the standard test of
time
I think this is the game that he
tells you it's gonna be game of the year
uh a genre bending
uh uh game this is a game that would
stand the test of time I think he knows
what he's capable of and I think this is
a time that he steps into that jacket I
think before he was wearing the jacket
as like a show or something I think this
time
he is the jacket like he he is God
Howard like we give him that name from
his previous accomplishments I think
he's showing you now why he's God Howard
could be and this is it right now and
the game looks great I'm gonna sit down
I'm gonna delve into it I'm still on uh
what's your record
it still has my brain and the reason why
I want to finish up Diablo so much is
because yeah I'm probably dabble in
Final Fantasy 16 what you're gonna get
it to right now but this star field has
me so intrigued in what I can do and
stuff that I I really don't have any
worries so and I just really can't wait
to play the actual game itself when it
comes out and I think it's going to live
up to every expectation that's that's
just my opinion of it I don't care about
the 30 frames versus 60 frames even
though I hoped that they would give them
opportunity
um maybe come later because they're
always tinkering and fixing and stuff
like that then don't say it now don't
tell people oh yeah we're gonna give you
60 frames later don't say anything just
let it pop uh with a patch and it'll be
a welcome surprise instead of people
always bad badgering you where is that
where is that so yeah let's combine
topics because I know it has to go so
this is your topic what did you get your
bars off you know there is a demo out in
these streets on that PlayStation five
what is going on
uh what's going on is I would actually
say
playing Final Fantasy throughout the
years you know
I would say the franchise kind of went
downhill after 10 12 was a that was a
good game but uh I would say 13 is when
the demise of Final Fantasy started
happening to me and then they decided
we're going to make two sequels to that
damn game so uh that we got to play uh
13 to X2 or 13-2 and then third and then
Lightning Returns so I played 15 and I
felt like 15 was a step right into the
back in the right direction to you know
what the franchise is about but it
wasn't the right direction you know it
it was kind of like
we're completely going off the mountain
but we ain't going anywhere we just
turned around like we're still in the
same spot just right on the edge of the
cliff
but I do think that you know seven
started to give me a little bit more
hope that you know they
this I first of all I want people in the
chat because I see this all the time on
Twitter this isn't an attack on whether
or not Final Fantasy is a turn-based
jrpg okay
this is an attack on whether or not
Final Fantasy lives up
to what we as Final Fantasy fans expect
from the brand we expect fantastic
stories great character development and
a world that always has some form of
hidden agenda
and I didn't I felt that a little bit in
15 but not a lot
it was okay in 13 but there was no like
real good character development there
were some characters that did okay some
that didn't
but when I played 16.
I still concerned but I went from
this is this game's gonna bomb to
okay maybe this game won't do something
words in the IOP chat come on now say
what you said you said that's it
well no I mean obviously it could
definitely be in that game of the year
Contender now okay because to be honest
like we got six games that generally get
game of the year because they always do
one more than the rest so I mean you got
Zelda Starfield Spider-Man
Final Fantasy 16 Diablo most likely
Maybe
you'll have uh that Harry Potter game
uh maybe Hi-Fi Rush forgot about that
yep it failed so long ago
there's two spots that
it like look there's been quality games
that's came out this year like Resident
Evil 4 you know Dead Space remake but I
don't know if idio because like I feel
like Resident Evil 4 is probably gonna
be on that list like when you come out
as a reboot you gotta really bring it
you know what I'm saying like and I
think final I think Resident Evil did
bring it but if a game like Final
Fantasy 16 comes out and it brought it
as a new game because every Final
Fantasy for the most part besides it's a
little bit of sequels they did like
Final Fantasy 10 they did a couple with
12. they did a couple of 13 they did
some DLCs of 15 like they generally are
on their own World thing there's not
like any direct sequels for the most
part besides those couple exceptions
that I said a new game I think will get
that nomination before a remake the only
time I see like remakes doing anything
yeah well unfortunately I think there's
a good chance raising before remake well
you go boycott the one I would break out
there you ain't gonna spit the the uh
the same verse and do a different beat
on the track I just I feel like 16
definitely has a chance to be in that
game of their Contender but I don't
think it's gonna win because I I do
think starfield's gonna hit higher than
16. and I think Zelda if Starfield falls
short it's definitely gonna win it the
only the only contenders I could see the
only contenders I see 100 beating is
what uh that can have potential to be
Zelda is Starfield I don't see
Spider-Man or 16 having a climbing game
that we saw would be Zelda like oh stop
it's just like when it comes down to it
16 felt nice to get the combat felt
pretty good I would still
prefer turn base but this is a good
middle ground you know the the mixture
between summons you know for those in
the chat that that watch like Naruto
like they're pretty much like the
there's characters in this world that
are pretty much in Cherokees they have
Demons Inside
So I I like that I like the Dilemma to
me Final Fantasy has always been at its
peak in the middle of a war you know
there's been certain games that has
avoided that but for the most part the
best Final Fantasy games is in the
middle of some conflict that kind of
starts at the beginning but it just goes
straight up in the Middle with his war
going on in this yeah so and you're in
full-blown War like literally one of the
one of the final fantasies that people
put like the top three like right after
seven right after nine right after six
is Final Fantasy Tactics
and that is literally the entire game is
about war
so it's just I think it's good man I I I
gotta see more of it I gotta see because
they kind of did this at 15 where they
did a lot of the marketing based off of
the summons right and how the summons
are going to interact with the world
yeah but then when you play 15
that's sometimes
so it does look like because
the Summit is in infused into a person
you're going to see more of that but
it's just like what they show me in that
demo
is that just gonna happen like once or
twice yeah or is that just gonna be a
frequent thing that we did see a couple
things like in the in in the directs
where we saw multiple of a variety of
summons fighting each other like
do you pick the summons that go out in
battle is it like a Pokemon kind of
thing it's like Titan I choose you I
don't know but I do feel like they
answered enough questions to make me
want to actually play the game to find
out no doubt so if you got some time in
the demo a little bit how are we feeling
about that Final Fantasy 16
yeah like I jumped into it and because
because they said they said it was
essentially the start of the game right
and all of your progress should go over
to the main game right so I jump into it
oh real quick so when I played it and I
talked to you it's like one of those
things where you start in the middle of
the game it seems like and then they
like okay this is where we were now
let's go back and tell you how we got
here right and and to me that kind of it
it's great because it's a great sort of
Storytelling tool but at the same time I
was like damn I I just want to make sure
this is actually the beginning of the
game and I'm not gonna go into the when
I play the final product and it's
different and you told me to you know
transfer my save over because again I
don't have a lot of time to play so I
don't want to have it necessarily be
redoing stuff that I've gone through
already
um so I like the fact that it did start
abruptly though I thought okay wait a
minute it starts in the middle of
something then it goes back
um what I liked about it and I'm usually
not the dude that really is in for the
cliches and the things that remind me of
other things in pop culture like
obviously you see this you play this and
it definitely has Game of Thrones all
over it right all over it
um but the good thing about Game of
Thrones and what I really enjoy about
Game of Thrones is that they have no
respect for your reverence of a factor
they don't care that they don't care
like yeah we're gonna die you're gonna
die
um and again I haven't played enough of
this to know that's gonna happen but
already with the attitudes I'm seeing
with some characters some characters are
like you can tell some characters are
overtly evil and then some characters
are just sort of you know they're Towing
the line and they have they have
intentions with which they may think are
pure but aren't necessarily so it's just
a matter of that stuff coming into play
it that's really going to grab me or not
the game the game looks beautiful
and looks absolutely gorgeous we talked
a little bit about the fact that the
performance mode isn't quiet in 60 and
you see a little bit of hiccups here and
there but in performance mode like I
switched over to the 30 just to see
where the graphical differences were and
I didn't really see anything substantial
at all like really like so run that at
60 if you can
um or performance if you can
um and then the combat a little bit that
I did see of combat I thought was cool
because again it's that middle ground I
thought ff7 remake was that middle
ground they gave you sort of a little
bit of the turn-based stuff right but
but slowing it down and allowing you to
sort of pick your stuff in real time
made it so you had to really think on
your feet as well so it was a little bit
of both and this is seems like it's
leaning more into the pure action and
when you have the combat director from
games like you know Devil May Cry 5 and
things like that you know what's funny
so in the first like two hours of like
well not two hours like the first half
of what I seen in that demo yeah was
more character development in 16 than I
saw in the majority of 15. yeah that's
crazy a lot of people have you know
issues with 15 right and obviously for
the team that made 15 went on to make
four Spokes and they got shut down
unfortunately yeah
um so yeah this is Yoshi P right exactly
you know we had to say 14 from the death
exactly you know so uh and again I'm not
gonna sit here we we talked about the
the the hypocrisy that existed about
your you know when Yoshi P was talking
about why there aren't people of color
in this or whatever but we talked about
the fact that we're going to point it
out and we're still going to play the
game because that's our our job is to
play the game and that is the job so
we're gonna play the game
um and I'm excited to play the game for
what it is
um
and I there's nothing that I saw there
that really turned me off man that
really turned me off it it as a fan of
ff6
I kind of feel like
it's it's in that vein where that some
really horrific things are going to
happen in the middle of this game I feel
some World altering events I feel like
you've got good intuition okay stay stay
long for this ride it's it's yeah yeah
so I'm excited for it I don't know again
I'm never home so playing on my PS5 is a
pain
um unless you use the handheld I mean I
could only get as far as the toilet with
the handouts I mean you you do have the
Rock Island it has a streaming
capability together yeah but again my
issue is my my crappy working okay
I will literally be playing it at five
frames they don't have an option to
download them
so so we'll see when I actually get to
to play it in depth but I'm excited for
it I am no doubt no doubt king um I know
this is not on Xbox but um you know it
gave us it's not a beta boy either
I'm talking about tell that part right
there and let them know at it let them
know what you said I'm not it's not
available
you were relegated to nakedness making
[Music]
and making the the downloading it him
signing into him making the character
and he's like that's all that's all yo
shout out to Paris great to finally be
cognatic person no doubt was a pleasure
brother see you in uh Pax West brother
Pax West we will see the whole team
pulling up the whole team did you get
your whatchamacall in the mail
um I Heard uh you get your Doctrine in
the middle
um
it was much easier upgrading the SSD and
the PS5 that it was I did open heart
surgery on this oh to get this job
to that genre the old dude that's in
there that's making people do stuff
that's a PC we know that's par for the
course
consoles we not supposed to be opening
them up and tearing out guts and putting
in new guts ah no no I'm not about that
man
until the actual game comes out if I
decide to even get there right now D4
um has has me like uh like that like I
told you before that game has me I'm
going to play it at some point but I
also said that about the Final Fantasy 7
remake I don't like certain practices
and I'm one of those dudes that if I'm
standing on my Square I'm just gonna
stand on my Square pulse Square
I got that if if you really want me to
play your games make them available
someplace else but
I do have a PlayStation file right and I
do I brought my Playstation for
exclusives there's no way in hell a
third-party company is supposed to have
exclusive like well then then go over
there marry him
oh you sound bitter you sound bitter is
over there because what it is is Sony
don't want you like that like obviously
if they ain't put a re they put a ring
on Bungie and they still let her go for
the streets obviously they know that you
ain't worth the squeeze oh man it's like
yeah you do whatever and you keep on I'm
gonna be exclusive to you like this is
you know that chick that keep bothering
me you talking about I'm not gonna date
nobody you could like I don't know I
just like the danger but you can though
so you said Sony don't love them like
that enough to put a ring on it showing
her Frailty you know Sunny
together it's like no other he's like
but you can go out and date others like
we are in an open relationship she's
like put Nelly Sony
don't like Xbox like that she already an
Xbox over there like what up love he
said you could think she like
um
I'll give you some stuff no no we want
the whole kitten caboodle
nah I don't really like what's going on
and I hope Phil gets mad enough to just
go over there Snapchat the whole Squad
this is like everybody go in the
building and just plant an Xbox flag and
then they'd be like what's this you work
for us oh man this guy right here look
it'll be crazy if if they like they
bought them like after this let's say
this ABK though don't go through and I
guess there's like some new leadership
or something over there at uh Square
Enix and they just walk up and they'll
be like
here's a check I don't care what it is
write it in there and then let's say
they get that deal through quicker than
that because it would be a lot quicker
thing to get time
they like they're like we're gonna put
this we're gonna we're gonna put rebirth
on uh on Xbox we're delaying it and um
it's not on Playstation anymore
and take us to court we'll see you in
court y'all messy look I give a ball so
quick
um look I was already sold on this game
prior to the demo they showed a lot of
it showed all the complexity of the
systems graphically looked phenomenal
I'm like I'm already getting then they
showed it twice at the place they
showcased remember so I was like all
right we know I'm good I'm I'm in I'm
not gonna hold y'all at it like because
I knew it was on the attic he put a
ticket on chat like yo we gotta talk
about this there's a new challenge it
gave it it gave it a year you know
contention so to speak and for me look
this game is so iron lordly let's just
get like that oh bro this is none of
that anime thing that you kick this is
Game of Thrones Final Fantasy like it is
your lord my like they in that time but
the thing that you gonna like kid
because y'all watch them anime the
beastininess of this thing called the
dominance like they running around King
it literally King they Runner kingdoms
are running around with human weapons of
mass destruction like bro they literally
it's like it looks like the East got a
dominant now to try to compete with our
dominant you know what I'm saying I I
think the reason that like the
disconnect is like they've done that in
Final Fantasy before but it was before
like the 3D era yeah so like you you saw
that like 2D like little Sprites like
you're seeing that type of energy now on
the big screen and for me and I know
King gonna love it this is not your your
this is not your brother's final fantas
ain't your little kid's final fan this
is the sex buddy you're murdered like
the language like like I saw a dominant
grab up because in a human form like
come here girl go on the corner before
I'm like yo squid this is unfiltered
this is this is I Final Fantasy after
dark oh the brutality the murder I might
have something to play in July yes I'm
tell King this is so you not only is it
lordly it is the most mature wildest
thing I've ever seen and then I'm gonna
tell you this let's go when Final
Fantasy the last one with the cars and
um
no I like that one okay so
I've ran out and got that game I didn't
wait for No Xbox I didn't wait for none
of that stuff but when it came on Xbox
it was day one it was day one but you
know you didn't play but it's cool
no I don't believe it was yeah
but it was a problem with the Xbox
even existed it was something that I'm
telling you guys I remember it was
something that made me say I'm getting
it on Playstation there's no way in hell
oh performance I think was baby yeah it
was performing I think it was digital
Foundry
nah I'm not doing that with this I think
so because there's no way in hell if a
game come out on both Xbox and
Playstation I'm going running by the
PlayStation version it was a reason why
I even think Xbox had the marketing
rights to it if I remember yeah but he
is right about performance
yeah because oh yeah shout out to Don
and talk he's right he said PS4 Pro was
out out and the 1X wasn't out at that
time that's what it was yeah I was
playing on my PS4 Pro yeah
bro I'm telling you right now look
graphically this game's got here on
cinematics now yes it has a lot of
hashtag just what interactive movie
energy you know but for me it's really
telling God tier like sequences God
tier-like stuff and like I said like
soft point there is performance I put it
on performance mode it's a little weird
with the dips here and there my only
nitpick I'm not I'm with attic I don't
know if I'm sold on the combat yet
because I like the Final Fantasy 7
remake if they go action you put up your
spells and you got the little slow mo
you're doing things in the mix and it's
feel more turn-based RPG this is
straight action shoot slash and some of
the boss is a little bullet bullet
spongy So In fairness to the game I only
play the demo I haven't seen the
complexity of the combat yet so I don't
want to say oh it's going to be just
this and simple I need to see more I
love the evade addict I love the evade
and they reward you for the evading
stuff doing that but I'm gonna tell
y'all right now this story is so fire
and heartfelt this is one of the best
demos to sell you if you was on the
fence you are this gives me like the
story gives me like mad Final Fantasy 9
Vibes the it
spoil you want when they you end the
demo you're gonna be like oh not nah
and then they they know they got it
because they thought they put the
pre-order since you like this little you
got something bro they had me like I
know that it just happened like that
yeah more energy King this is for you
I'm telling you I know how you get that
yeah I'll talk to the iron bank in July
Talk to the I am back sorry we got we
don't never ask you always put the money
back in the podcast I am baked cause we
get King David this place it'd be for
birthday present yeah oh yeah come on
come on I'm not going right now I'm I'm
not going to allow anything
and you still have not played any Street
Fighters oh no no I've been playing
Street Fighter a little bit and I'm I
want to get back to uh fight night
Fridays that's another segment because
we're going to be getting back to Fight
Night Friday
but I'll spoil it
the voice actor for Clive yes
I know it sounds like Calvin I know I'm
watching dub so
words
here's the thing I always do I always
like multitask to like a huge degree I
just don't sit there and like I gotta be
able to hear and understand what's going
on so you wouldn't accept he did the
subtitles no I I I listen dub is the
English voice oh no we did it the same I
know you guys are real big on sub like
that no no no no no I'm good I left this
before I'm good no no I didn't change
anything no the only time I got that
option right I'm gonna sit there and
listen to it the only way I do that is
when it's a purely Japanese setting like
like a ghost Shima then I'll do that
because
this ain't really I don't be talking
Bronx languages
[Music]
the only time I do it on anime is if
like something crazy happened and dub
I'm like I can't wait where is it and
stuff listen I'm with you though but
that's what I said I want to give the
Clive voice actor
his FL like this is one of the most
heartfelt and again without spoiling
please end the demo please complete the
demo Y'all Gonna understand there's
levels to voice act I already got this
dude already I haven't played again they
already won an Academy awarded Mama this
person is amazing so yeah salute to that
and that was all I was gonna say on that
before we got anything else
he has a lot of Jon Snow energy not a
Jon Snow yeah a lot of oh Clive did that
Clive did that I fell every moment from
Clive so yeah I'm there continue hold on
a second all right we have some super
chats and then got one more bill to pay
and then we'll get into a rock talk hold
on and I don't ask you one time so if
you got it yeah we're almost out of here
I know we got to read that out too yeah
official for sure
[Music]
I'm starting the hashtag not my fable
movement because the last thing I want
from Fable is a cinematic gameplay
experience I need to see more before I'm
hyped you know what I like about that
that's fair you're talking hot Graphics
if the graphics is hot he out
I'm actually with that energy it is like
I don't mind
what the graphics look like as long as
it intrude on what the gameplay could
have been yeah but we don't even know
what anyway let me
know
there we have zip Davis five dollars for
chat saying respect his name the Swami
General King David Mr 99 aka Mr ooh
we Happy Father's Day to all the dads
out there especially Big Daddy Phil wow
that 80 generator
does not ever happen
[Applause]
doesn't make it to Xbox is because
PlayStation already bought time
inclusivity it would be very different
today yes it probably would be I would
agree I would agree yeah especially
they're going down the tubes he said
somebody clip that
and we have briarius five dollars I
think y'all missed the one the one more
thing Phil's shirt he I I mentioned
hexan I'm so excited to see what he's
going to do with that franchise yes as
soon as they buy them you'll see what
happened I can see what it is so let's
get dude stop uh C blocking
CMA black CFA blockers I like that I
like that we have a slim Reaper five
dollars question what score did you guys
give Jeff Healey show Jeff kiwi show
because nobody's talking about it so why
are we trying to downgrade Xbox show
Happy Father's Day odd six Paws I'll
give it a seven maybe seven yeah
the only reason why you're bumping it up
is because y'all was there listen over
there
was funny there
their seven decreased my PlayStation to
like a four because it's like you you
gave those points yeah to another people
oh yeah they had remake I know I don't
appreciate that I don't appreciate the
the Final Fantasy that you could have
put on your show and your date I don't
know
signs are you slipping bro
all money ain't good money man making
money stakeholders like money no I'm not
talking I'm talking about Sony taking
money all money ain't good money yeah
for them you keep on acting like it
can't happen and you're gonna wake up in
a ditch no no you're gonna look up and
say it is
weird that they chose to make another
show look better than their own show
don't do that man let that dude flounder
by itself let him go do it you know it's
funny King they're they're throwing out
mad energy like soap Microsoft used to
do let's let everyone else show our best
stuff but not us and you notice my
so because we're already gonna show our
uh you take that y'all do that I'm so
happy addict you spoke out about it
before because you was so upset with
Microsoft doing things on his back on
the front line first look how it flip
right do you see yeah so it seems like
Sony is like where
we're e for everyone I mean it's the
most eyes is on Kegley stage though I
don't care about all that bro yeah but
it could have been PlayStation and Final
Fantasy was put more and more together
now when people talk about that huge
reveal of rebirth it's gonna be the
summer game Fest at the end of that
scent yes and they did give Spider-Man's
release like you didn't have to do that
like y'all did y'all not looking well
[Music]
and we got a okay the Liz remember for
two years you can go ahead and leave
King I'll I'll stay around no no I got
some funny stuff to talk about yeah I
just got to bounce for Father's Day I'm
cooking A Feast for my family dad and
father-in-law no doubt just want to say
I am so impressed with the rock Ally I
definitely going to be upgrading SSD and
getting that Asus EGP that's B oh [__]
you're getting the 40 90 with it oh yeah
40 90 that's just the next level with it
we have X down the other topical again
two dollars Super Chat why y'all
disrespecting towerborne
I like that it look it reminds me a
little bit of uh Guardian Heroes when
it's on on this side shout out to skinny
City skylines to look good too yeah we
got Gerald Mack member for two years two
dollars Super Chat rock climbing
simulator look really good
it looks just like another rock climbing
simulator this time you didn't have to
use your glasses
don't come for us unless we send for you
we don't know see this this thing has
potential we already know what this is
we already know what we got DLC plus
over here but we don't know what this is
but it looked good I mean let's just
just from the looking assets that's what
we do it looked better than it
72 remember for 28 months Lord bronze
Matt booty did say the giant bomb that
uh Starfield was to be released if it
were to be released today it would have
the fewest bugs in any Bethesda game
ever my booty was outside with that
that's a that's a statement be careful I
mean I'll be on my king I ain't gonna be
on that temper expectations
they're not tempering anything and that
that's a huge statement so we'll see if
anything you know they'll be held to it
then we have BT Maverick 707 10 super
chat this is to help save the Suave
Madagascar porcupine that lives in this
not through that's living in my mouth
we up to eight hundred likes y'all we
get to a thousand likes King is gonna
play Final Fantasy 16. if if all right
if we get to a thousand likes before the
show is over I'll play Final Fantasy and
I stream let's go let's get him on Final
Fantasy Game of Thrones
play these games with y'all man open up
a new account
uh thank you guys love what you do what
you guys bring to the community King we
getting out our cigars out soon the FTC
is gonna crumble brother I got my cigars
sitting right here ready to pop and I
can tell you I can show you you they're
right here so shout out to
um Crazy Lou I'm telling you right now
as soon as it happened live on there
and I'm gonna pop a bottle of champagne
pow it's over
let's see what happens let's see what
happened yeah we got Robert Kelly five
dollars but people can't complain about
Starfield when Zelda is Game of the Year
for many Starfield is doing a lot I mean
highlights how we need the pro consoles
after or he's saying that he can't
complain about Starfield when Zelda is
their game of the year so he's kind of
they only kept it for Zelda because
that's all they got
how we need the pro consoles after all
this is what I'm gonna push back on this
we you know we get the the promises made
at the start of a generation of a
certain special size secret sauces and
things that to date have still not come
to fruition in any real way
um and that because I'm Gonna Keep It
Whatever 30 I'm gonna play I'm gonna
play store field on the PC I'm not
worried about that
but on the console with all the things
they've talked about that they can do
and yes Starfield was not fully
developed under Microsoft's tutelage or
whatever the case may be but there are
things built into this console that
should be able to help it get there
um and maybe again maybe that's
something they're working on for the
future they're not saying it but there
are things built into this console that
should help it get there and they have
we haven't seen that in hardly any game
so it's time we need to see what all
this Special Sauce pause is about Todd
is like yo I don't want to do all that I
want it where is it this is the thing
but but where is that one of the
platforms where it's at it's 60.
what if that frame rate is floating
around and doing the Final Fantasy 16
and zip it in and doing all type of what
if it's a wow unstable 45 unstable 50.
and lock it down at 40.
they're gonna come for them oh these
guys said they could barely you know I
go it's a lose-lose situation that is
but I feel you on the way they Market it
I will give people push no push back on
that I'll let them have that one let me
see then we have X done again the otaku
five dollars I'm glad Xbox finally has a
game that can match the Uncharted series
is giving it competition in the climbing
simulator shot and run wow
and we have bone slave five dollars to
hold me let's gross
next gen isn't just graphics and frame
Starfield is bringing next 10 systems
programming and scripting only possible
on current gen consoles that is true a
lot of the guts cannot could not be done
on priorities people always say but we
always say yo we want to see new things
in gaming want to see gaming push
forward doing things that we never seen
before from a gameplay perspective that
it happens we have a friend you know
what I'm saying like you can't have it
both ways if it's at the expense of a
revolutionary experience game is about
to make a choose until your points off
yeah it's a platform for you
at the end of the day as long as
Starfall comes out and it hits the way
it's supposed to people will Overlook it
but starfo doesn't hit well we're done
then it's going to be why this game need
to be 30.
I think it's gonna I think it's gonna
turn out well for them I do yeah all
right that we got hold on damn it this
thing keeps throwing back
um let me see
our mic five dollar Super Chat did
Microsoft own Bethesda at the time Aaron
made a 60 FPS tweet past and future
internal Microsoft Studio titles seem to
be holding the 60fps promise good
question I'm not sure I think it was
before I'm gonna say it before the set
of Max was required yeah I think at some
point in time all games will be 60
frames yeah
um I just think that performance mode
yeah they'll hit later on because the
truth of the matter is that a lot of
these TVs these newer TVs if you're
getting your TVs to play on these
consoles they have built-in things to
smooth that stuff out so yeah that
Samsung that I got in that living room
that's why I had to ask you that
question uh because I'm gonna tell you
right now I went and brought that
because we needed something for the
living room and I went and got this TV
and this is my first 2023 television I'm
a television connoisseur and I kind of
stepped away from it I thought I paid 10
grand for that television I was like I'm
never doing it again right and I stepped
away from it and I said well let me get
this TV and it's the smaller size
television I got in my 50 inch
I'm like and it's going to go in in my
grandson
and I'm like yeah man let me see what
this TV's like brother
it is it was the cheapest television
that I have
but it's the best television in my house
yeah
and this TV the stuff that's inside like
I hooked it up before I even put on
anything else I played with my series X
with the controller from the cons like
from the television that's crazy so I'm
like this is nuts then when I put my
series X to it it took it to a whole
different level these televisions now
are more necessary for our hobby than
anything else if y'all get a chance go
out and check out what's going on in
these new TVs okay yeah for sure
um
why does this keep scrolling me back
it's annoying because there's a lot of
people putting in super fast they trying
to extend us Alex the scores up remember
for 21 months Lord bronze shout out to
the little black man hopefully we get a
little breath man a little brown man
next time
Lord bronze good afternoon IOP can't
wait for Starfield but everyone better
not sleep on south of midnight
compulsion is a sleep hit Studio love
y'all peace that is for sure I want to
say I want to see what that is what it
is first
but we like what they try to do I like
that castle crust type of game too like
uh I think it was four player side
scrolling something at the time that was
the tower
and we got Soma King five pound Super
Chat just remember Sony we're looking to
make Starfield exclusive before the
acquisition thank Phil because Starfield
is looking to be a game changer actually
well they still out here with the
petitions if you look on Twitter it was
crazy if that would have happened there
would be no complaining no it won't it
won't but because they didn't buy the
whole company they just bought every you
know it's funny they did it to Square
Enix and they try to do it Bethesda
we're not going to buy the company
because we can't afford it well you know
what we can't afford we can make all of
your games kind of exclusive what's the
difference like you know what I like
addict I love the fact right now that
all these dudes they have powerful PCS
oh man I got powerful PCS right there's
no need for Xbox right
sense petition
then we have ksati five dollars salute
to the lawyers and fathers on this
Sunday my idea for Microsoft for Star
fuel allow us to export our custom
created ships to 3D printed in real life
at a fee that'd be awesome
your your phallic symbol
and 3D printed
then we have a couple of niggles
oh man Xbox said if you want it bigger
get it in Black oh man so we're going to
have start because these people are
trying to make us trip so much they're
gonna have to start reading super chats
this is crazy but everybody knows where
the niggles thing comes from so that's
funny
the other day you wasn't here and they
they said mad of them trying to get me
to slip up they love trying to get you
crazy
that we got uh a lot of Metroid member
for one year two lots of a chat guess
the black s will pop out sun was
sacrifice
[Music]
y'all are doing the most no
Big Rich
[Music]
this [__] a lot of fraudulent dudes out
here I'm the real one hey yo shout out
to the best gaming podcast out here
thank you appreciate it absolutely love
lessons
we got THX 1138 five dollars Super Chat
re4 ff16 Zelda tears of the Kingdom
Spider-Man 2 are all more of the same
sequels Starfield is a whole new game
experience Bethesda has Game of the Year
hands down yeah if you look at it that
way then yes 100 I don't know did they
pay the keys yet oh man
then we have X dondeo Taco two dollar
Super Chat the summon gameplay made OG
Star Fox look next gen Jesus you need to
stop that's just eight on another level
brother you gonna be fine tears and
gonna get Awards relax don't be feeling
threatened now they're gonna get the
Nintendo Awards the best Halloween
edition we can't hold our trophy
because it's slathered flipping all over
the place Falls
there we got Robert Keller two dollars
Super Chat square is is intimidated by
big X and little man
I had to get down and lay down pause
okay we got JD gamer remember for two
years 50 Super Chat
brother thank you bro let's get messy I
want PlayStation to try and buy Square
then I want Microsoft to come and plop
the three times PlayStation off a big
bag on the table in front of the
investor saying you can get with this or
you can get with them
oh man what they need to do is start
coming around embracing right now every
time yeah
imagine like we keep talking about
Square Enix or you know Capcom imagine
they bought them brace your group like
whatever thing and then king would be on
super profit oh my God what was this
deal go through you're gonna see it with
the prophecy yeah because Ken said that
that's the homie he was like they're
holding it if that go through the hole
in that oh we'd never go ahead and I
mean it kind of makes sense to me it
makes sense it's funny but it makes
sense then we have THX level 38 again
two dollars to be tap regards to Sony
and square you are not the father
damn man all right then we have puckish
Rogue one hundred five dollars for chat
did you hear the actor say it's icon
time like a Power Ranger you had me
laughing wow funny is it icon or Akon
how they say icon
that's Final Fantasy lingo which one how
you say it the actor when they say it's
icon time in ff16 did you say icon or
acot I don't remember I don't know I
don't know then we have X done the otaku
five dollars Super Chat Cog don't start
it's not about Graphics taking control
from the players so that you can have an
interactive cut scene is what I don't
like that's what you don't like but
there's a strong subset of Gamers that
like very deep narrative with high
graphical Fidelity just because you
don't like it doesn't mean it's a bad
game open your horizons to stop it
oh God I got jumped crazy give me a
second this is crazy we have a we have
Lou Cipher oh that's the homie with the
6.66 Super Chat the Demonic Super Chat
appreciate that that Howard got Todd
Howard said the Starfield watch will
only come with 30 minutes of time not 60
for Quality okay wow that's kind of
funny
we got gaming Forte five dollars Super
Chat Happy Father's Day Lords you're
special every day but today is about you
for one day I'll share my king love and
as always hey Lord Lords
[Laughter]
I don't know about the other two they
ain't gonna say nothing to you man yeah
that we have
he's farting 661. five dollar Super Chat
I'm so hyped for Starfield that I was
able to get to Starfield constellation
Edition I'm very frugal with my money
like King I just had to have it a lot of
people
these statues make a difference
only when it comes to Game Pass is he
frugal
tell the truth Sheena though there we
got black Road in three five seven five
dollar Super Chat great show Lords
addict how do you like the new Starfield
headset I got the controller and it
feels almost as good as my Elite two
Happy Father's Day
it feels good I got the controller
um the headset
the headset it feels like the earmuffs
are a little bit bigger oh really but I
wouldn't say that like it's like a
drastic uh difference between this one
and the black one okay
then we have Grumble Grumble two dollars
to the chat we have the Samsung s95b and
it still stuns us yes it is a fantastic
TV on deep discounts since it's last
year's TV but I get it and then temper
in the chat I want the Samsung s5c but
no Dolby vision is giving me pause this
TV is so bright you do not need Dolby
Vision trust me I get it I got over that
fomo I got over that fomo they're never
gonna do dope because they don't want to
pay that money trust me when you put
Dolby Vision side by side with their HDR
10 or 10 plus it is you don't need it
you don't need it then we got Tyson
Lewis 20 Super Chat always blessing to
tune in I'm super happy for you all this
has been a dope few weeks also it's so
dope to see Xbox acknowledge the hashtag
Hold the Line yeah that was a super dope
that's a beautiful beautiful thing I
want to get greeny on here yeah for sure
we have Carmelo Rivera ten dollars on
the chat yo King thank you for your
Father's Day wishes at the beginning of
the podcast definitely needed that Happy
Father's Day to all my underappreciated
strong Brothers holding it down Hold the
Line absolutely thank you Brothers It's
hugely uh appreciated that you even uh
gave that back to me because a lot of us
don't get the recognition or credit that
we deserve So for anybody that feels
anything Happy Father's day
bro absolutely then we got X dondeo Taco
five dollars so [__] hold and try while
occasionally dodging for a five minute
battle is fun at holding triangle I know
you're okay with sacrificing gameplay
cinematics but I'm not bro that's just
what you like your one style of gamer
you don't represent the millions
millions disagree with you and you see
the sales
it's so funny that people got their idea
of what gaming is supposed to be and
that's that's it nobody else counts
Augustus member for 21 months Lord
Brahms I'm afraid for the day when
Diablo 4 comes to Game Pass I'll never
be able to log in to play the game game
changer that's true that's gonna be
crazy our server game is sick
yeah and we all caught up okay let's go
right right so I gotta pay these bills
bills bills bills
everybody meet your mic
all right ready
I don't expect an answer
this episode is brought to you by bird
dogs bird dogs is a company that
specializes in bringing you the most
comfortable shorts bathing suits pants
and polos on the market the specially
engineered built-in Comfort liners for
their shorts and pants are for any
cross-disciplined workout or Leisure
activity which enables customers to run
swim and relax all in the same pair of
shorts or pants so
even if the prospect of technically
going commando doesn't get you excited
the fact of the matter is that bird dogs
just make you look good
bird dog stretch khakis and shorts are
designed to fit Slimmer through the
thigh and leg giving you a truly
sculpted look bird dog shorts do the
exact same thing as Lululemon shorts but
they fit way way better they also fit
way better than regular shorts and pants
that are made of stiff restricting
cotton bird dogs has fixed this issue by
inventing Cloud knit fabric you know uh
everybody has some kind of plow
cloud-powered technology now it's crazy
that looks just like khaki but stretches
so you get a waist Slimmer fit without
having to sacrifice movement bird dogs
also uses an anti-stink sweat wicking
fabric that keeps you cool and dry all
day long because as I've said in the
past swamp stack is real so that's great
that bird dog has that now for me my
dress style is changed considerably
since my younger days as someone who
probably took the the whole baggy Trend
a little too far through the 90s and now
as a 47 year old man I now prefer a more
flattering sort of form-fitting look to
my wardrobe you know so I can accentuate
this uh adonis-like body that I've
chiseled to Perfection over my nearly
you know half century of existence but
no the fact is that someone who is
constantly on the move and sweats
profusely unfortunately bird dogs allows
me to constantly stay on a move stay
cool dry and flexible throughout my ever
hectic days additionally and this is
just a cool side note I love supporting
a brand that has these weird naming
conventions that they have for their
products with polos called Jacques
straps uh and shorts such as Teddy rub
skins and tight wads and pants called
John D coxwellers and Lee I did a lot of
Coca so if you're ready to join me and
finally dress like an adult and show off
those massive quads and calves it's time
to get bird dogs so go to birddogs.com
pool and enter promo code pool p-o-o-l
for free Yeti style tumbler with your
order that's birddogs.com slash pool for
free Yeti style tumbler you won't want
to take your bird dogs off we promise
you
foreign
who don't sacrifice gameplay for
cinematics so more than all your just
once try again they're still selling bro
why can't we have a world where they all
exist why can't there only be one style
of game open your horizons sir you're
exposing yourself anyway moving up so we
got um young Trey ads 52 2000 Super Chat
King appreciate the Love on the graphic
love this show got that so yeah I think
he did he did the general joint is that
is that you mean yeah I think that was
him no doubt no doubt anyway we gonna
move into this next topic we're gonna go
on so here's the thing y'all we got the
rock Ally I'll drop this off with me
first because uh me and Saul obviously
have it and then you know Alex hasn't
seen it in case we'll be getting it
shortly but um look it's out it's out in
these streets you know a lot of people
have not have their hands on the device
you know we know Xbox has kind of been
behind it but I'll start off with me you
know I'll get off the the rep let's
let's get to the good you know actually
I actually want to get to the bad first
let me do the bad first you know this is
a Windows device through and through
this is a Windows 11 device if you come
in there thinking this is switch energy
and everything is going to be so easy
and accessible to move around no you
gotta do your Windows updates you got to
do your assets um Asus uh my Asus app
updates Windows store updates you know
make sure you treat it as if it's a PC
first another thing I would highly
recommend is the little shortcut keys in
the back if you use those in conjunction
with the directional pad you can pull up
the keyboard easier so that you could
type stuff like that if you're the guy
that's not going to use a hub and USB
stuff so that part you can tell from a
UI standpoint there is Jank it's a
learning period you know what I mean so
I will say that
um another thing I would say
first person is amazing Fighters
it's solid but I wouldn't say high
competitive I wouldn't say like I
wouldn't use this if I'm really doing
some online some tournament placing
because sometimes it's a little
sensitivity with this I forgot what this
is called not the traditional Saudi
Style d-pad with this part right here
these Corners are attached so that's my
little nitpick there some your movements
are going to come out but if you want
extreme preciseness I wouldn't recommend
it for high competitive play and the
last thing just like the steam deck the
battery life
that battery life is no joke man you
gonna go through some joints so if
you're playing these high demanding
games Next Generation games you will go
through so make sure you got your ally
battery pack or you know you got an AC
joint
um those are the probably the most
things I would say for bad as far as bad
you know but again just the fact it's
Windows 11. now let's get to the good
now as far as that
this is the best playing experience of
video games on a handheld period period
like when it comes to
let's just say the entire
putting like first of all you already
know how I feel about the offset analogs
with the Xbox controller so FPS is god
tier on this like that is amazing and I
think what what people want to really
get at home when they get a hold of this
device is they're going to see how it
controls second of all 1080p 120 hertz
vrr in the Box you know the best sound
you've ever heard on a handheld this is
Dolby Atmos at its finest to the point
where I got to turn this thing down this
thing is sounding like an orchestra is
going on you can also um and it has the
free license with it you can also use it
in a headset I wish it's coming from a
person that has a steam deck oh yes this
is not even steam deck is that picture
gameplay playing games
picture and sound it's not close like
this is beating steamed up on that on
the high end where steam that gets them
is the lower Fidelity games and having a
little bit more battery life based on
your configuration I will give steam
that that and steam that got them on
interface it comes valve moving around
Pro like their UI is way better it
literally it's way better this this is
in the infancy stages and Microsoft and
windows 11 are going to have to make an
official UI that is fully integrated
into this device so that that's my thing
there I will say there's a feature
called rsr that allows you to um pretty
much when games don't have FSR you can
lower and put something at like 720p as
opposed to 1080p if you're a frame rate
guy if you want to get them 60 frames
and stuff like that you bring you you
activate that feature for a game that
doesn't have FSR and you can try to get
those frame rates that you want 120
hertz on this is insane I will say that
it's a shredded battery but it's insane
and last thing I'll say yeah no solves
back well um key games I played Pro
Forza 5 on this oh my God God's here God
here ridiculous um again Dusty I'm a
destiny guy being that this is Windows
it's not blocked by the steam deck or
the Linux OS amazing and that's the not
for a handheld no you can play
full-fledged Destiny and it is playing
exceptional so that's that I did Diablo
4 had some tweak in there with my
settings now I got my frames up shout
out to Kai box who hooked me up with the
good settings on that did dbo at 120 20
Hertz oh pretty amazing you can do VR on
this as well a lot of stuff so look oh I
did that streaming on game the death
stranding on Game Pass what Provera
fields did you pick up for because I I
did you do the accelerated mode yet or
um which would be accelerated like that
I heard they like have some like boost
mode yeah when you plug in it's you can
go 30 Watts I'm all all the way with
with the boosting on all that
um yeah this thing it's j it's a beast
it's an absolute beast when it comes to
the playing of games and yeah I'll let
uh soft jump in if he's back is it the
Neo Geo of handhelds
this is top tier I can see why Xbox got
behind the key the key difference is the
fact that I'm not just locked to Steve
first of all Stephen plays amazing on
this right but oh Steven Plays amazing
all your Steam games you log in you got
all your Steam games you play all your
Steam games no problem
that's crazy then epic game store I play
I think I downloaded Destiny over there
just to test it epic game store game how
that works so to stay up front but I got
a Diablo from Battlenet you know you got
Ubisoft EA Game Pass PC game pass I
could play def stranding remember that's
on PC game that's exclusive on that and
you can download them local it's an
amazing streaming device if you want to
stream it's Wi-Fi six in this and you
can stream and it's amazing and you can
save battery life so that's the beauty
of the device it it has that
functionality as far as where how you
want to play the games where you want to
play the games and then the Fidelity is
just top tier it's a great device great
um initial setting just get through I
send people some tips and tricks if
you're struggling just moving around
windows with it and what settings to
turn off there's some settings that
Windows has in the background that can
take away from performance and there's
some cool Reddit things I can send but
I'm impressed it's about about a weekend
I can't stop playing it I take it
everywhere and the only thing I think I
want Ally bro you guys got to have
official Doc license for yourself so
that I could get the ethernet because
something about the download speeds I
think from a lot of these store shop
fronts are a little slow that's it
that's what I got oh so I'm still is I
know yeah if I'm taking a phone call but
uh yeah King you'll be joining the the
Allies we'll be getting you to join and
get one of your joints in there you know
that's a fantastic
speaking to the I am banking out of
these back but uh saw quickly you know
your thoughts on it yeah accept my
apologies
Father's Day food ordering drama you
don't know I'm good you're good
yeah so first impression when I took it
when I first got it unpacked it I was
like okay
aesthetically this is not as premium
looking of a thing as as the the steam
deck right the steam bed just looks you
know thinking of the black console is
very Sleek even like uh ergonomically I
think it kind of feels more like a
controller than the rock Ally itself but
you know just looking at like the the
chassis and kind of the plasticy feel of
it and aesthetically I was not super
impressed off the rip right and then
when I looked inside the box I had to
laugh at this on the top of the the top
cover there's something that's that's
kind of placed in there and like what
the heck is this so I'll pull this out
and it's and it's like this cardboard
stand it it is literally little Nintendo
labo cardboard stand so you can stand up
your rock right so it was at the event
when I went to the event that was what
they was using as a stand
so then I I throw it on right and again
as I knew what was coming but I forgot
so I go in and I'm like oh no I forgot
this is a Windows 11 machine this is the
windows 11 PC that's what it is right so
what does that entail that entails
a number of updates whether it be to
Firmware too specifically to the the
windows OS specifically to the AMD
drivers specifically to the Armory crate
uh front end so there's a lot of things
that need updates before you can even
really talk about playing games on this
right and then with car Cog went and did
surgery put into two the two terabyte uh
nvme so that takes even longer so the
setup process if you're an impatient
person and you're not familiar with
Windows and working your way around
windows it can be extremely frustrating
it can be it could really really turn
you off if that's not what you're
expecting and shout out to Asus because
Asus if you go to their website they
have a number of different tutorials on
how to you know do all this stuff step
by step from the moment you unpack it
and telling you what you need to do so
it's very good about that but internally
in the box like when you in terms of
like instructions that they give you or
on-screen things if you do not know
Windows around ready you don't really
know what to do except apart from
whatever they prompt you to do but it
isn't intuitive right so it doesn't
really have a a console or or a handheld
front end like that Armory crate is kind
of that but it's not quite there right
so once you get past all of that right
and I I had to go through like two bios
upgrades one of them which gimped my
freaking performance I didn't realize
until after
um
so those are the growing pains but when
you finally get down to the game plan
the options that you have in terms of
gameplay and the innards of this machine
which betrays the look of it because the
innards are are special for what it is
um for what it is there are machines out
there that are fifteen hundred dollar
machines right the ironyo next and
things like that
um but again it's a 1500 machine as
opposed to a 700
but this is they they uh I had a host
they're fighting with you yeah yeah yeah
there's argument it's Father's Day is
get out of there get out of there oh
yeah
[Music]
I'm getting side eyes already too so
yeah I I got a boogie
um let me just say uh what I was gonna
say about the um the PlayStation Cloud
thing real quick please let me set you
up um no just you set it up real quick
all right so real quick because this is
this is a combo yeah um somebody's
starting the testing of cloud streaming
uh PS5 games PlayStation PlayStation
Plus premium members will get access to
stream PlayStation 5 games without
having to download them to a console and
then on their official blog we have very
exciting news we're currently testing
Cloud streaming for supported
PlayStation 5 games this includes
Playstation Plus game catalog and game
Trials as well as supported digital
PlayStation 5 titles that players own
when the future launches cloud game
streaming for supported PlayStation 5
titles will be available for use
directly on your PlayStation 5 console
as a premium member and they said we we
it's important for premium members to be
able to enjoy as many games possible via
Cloud streaming as more games continue
to launch on the PlayStation 5 console
we look forward to adding Cloud
streaming capability for PS5 titles in
addition to PS3 4 and classic titles
already available for members to stream
okay okay well I mean at this point in
time it was supposed to be a whole
segment Buck was supposed to come out
and we were going to go into how we
invented the Internet we should have
done that first yeah we should have done
it how uh you know it was a real play on
on Al Gore inventing the internet and
you know now that you know we invented
Cloud streaming and we're going to start
piecing it out to you guys and allowing
you guys to partake in what we have
invented
um it was going to go a longer I'm still
going to give you that skid I'll
probably put that skit out on Twitter
and have some fun with that but I'm
seeing now how Sony is slowly making
that turn and making that uh bending
around the corner to actually meet where
we all are at right
um it's good to see that they will start
incorporating that into their the system
I'm making that an option I guess they
wanted to see how it worked for
Microsoft and other uh companies and now
this is something that they're pursuing
actively and openly yes all right uh and
it will we'll get to that point where
games will be day and day uh hopefully
they can look at the game pass model
being that now you guys like how Game
Pass is right now
um and they can start doing the same
things as Game Pass listen
imitation is the greatest form of
flattery that's what all this is for you
and success dictates and predicts where
you will go right business-wise I think
you're a little bit slower foot but I'm
glad that you jumped on
uh now Cloud works right now cloud is a
thing right now uh streaming is a thing
now right this is something that we like
yet yes are you saying it like you got
to give kids the vegetables you're
ridiculous it's all of a sudden now it
makes you stronger right yes you like
your milk now right yes yes yes
okay I just like to watch you guys and
all your little stupid narratives flip
and folding Falls
don't want but y'all need because you
guys stop I don't like my stuff
screaming yeah yeah I like nice stuff
native and Sony would never do in facts
right Sony is doing all the stuff I said
they was gonna do to you and now you
like it right
yes yes yes
what was that cartoon it was it was
chilly Chilly Willy because they were
like he's like uh more pancakes
and then and then when he goes taking
the bite he's like no money no
[Laughter]
I can't solved remember these cartoons
like it's like
they all forcing That Base to flip a lot
of the narratives that they were so anti
against and to see people have to defend
it it's hilarious we we would never you
know Sony would never we value our
exclusions over there we have never put
it in the service because and PC will
never PC getting it but but it's only a
year later we'll never stream you know
because streaming is oh
yeah
it's you would do anything like there's
nothing that you won't do like you guys
is for the streets your show showed you
for the streets now Cloud streaming now
help help you're just gonna help help
it's looking stranger but you see people
some people are really panicking like
the Panic that's what we're used to yo
so yo shout out to this old way
he likes it he really like it really
likes them they got the over yeah yo we
love you guys Happy father Happy
Father's Day do you think appreciate
everything bro about to beat my legs
yeah go a little go do it
please no doubt Papa King in the
building you already know go back to the
wrong tunnel yeah so that I mean again
so like I said once you get down to the
nitty-gritty of playing games and you
realize what the innards of this machine
could do
um I threw on the street fighter six I
threw on what the heck I threw on the
lies of P demo I threw on Jedi Survivor
oh you went for it and what else oh
survive what was your frames like what
was you doing on that so Survivor
yeah I had a mess with the setting so
but you can get it to 60 if you do if
you you know do this the 720 with the uh
the rsr also upscaling
um but the options you have to get all
of these games to higher frame rates
while still looking good
um it's impressive it's impressive and a
lot of it happens at the hardware level
right so you have software
implementation you also have Hardware
implementation you can just kind of
decide what stuff you want to do in
conjunction with one another or one
thing or another if you want to
sacrifice the the 1080p resolution to go
to seven to 20p you have these upscaling
options or you could you can choose to
run 1080P and a lot of games will run at
60 but you can get that 40 sweet spot
again that that we were talking about
with the steam deck which 40 at that
screen size
um really does feel super super smooth
so you have a lot of options more so
than what the steam deck can provide you
in terms of the ability to run these
games at different sort of resolutions
and quality levels so it's super
impressive the fact that again it is it
is a Game Pass machine basically now you
can have be a Game Pass stuff on the PC
natively in addition to all these other
storefronts that if you're a PC Gamer
you have them at the at the at your
hands right now right you can do steam
you can do Ubisoft you can do uh you
know uh what you would call that epic
epic everything everything is there so
it is it's impressive what it can do
it's still clumsy it's still and it's in
its infancy stages it will only get
better and the fact is because you have
that support from like a Microsoft and
because the price point is such where
this is a commercial product that you're
able to purchase at Best Buy My Hope and
my belief is that the support will be
there right so it's not like it's one of
these things that's going to get
abandoned and you stop getting updates
and you know it's dead in the water and
stuff like that that's not going to
happen with this which is what's super
impressive and interesting about it um
like I said there are more expensive
handhelds out there that are more
powerful but you're talking about twice
the price of this right
um so as the potential for a commercial
product to sort of break through even in
a way that the steam deck has
um simply because you know valve is not
really chosen to sell the steam deck on
anything other than their own sort of
platform you know really it's not out
there in stores so this is is super
impressive I'm excited to keep messing
with it because again they could they're
continuing to find ways to get a little
more juice out of it
um and you're gonna see some impressive
frame rates and some impressive looking
games uh for this screen size one gripe
another and I hate this no go for it I'm
mad these screens have too much Bezel
give me the full screen experience I
looked at it I'm like damn it man this
mad bezel on here there's a lot of
unused real estate on the screen and it
makes me a little bit mad but I get it
you got to keep the price down a little
bit but again 120 hertz 1080p screen at
this price point is very very and I
think for me solve it's like seeing this
screen right here having the ability to
have the game look at all the apps epic
games you could play where you want to
play this is a huge that's the deal for
a guy like me who again is not locked
into the Steam OS I could play where I
want look at that bro and then oh make
sure you put it in offline mode for guys
if you want an airplane or whatever and
windows you got to put it in offline
mode and then the app will tell you hey
you can put it offline now now okay some
games is all oily online that I found
out because I give you like a few here
and then the gears tactics was one of
them but everything comes from the steam
you can put in like offline mode
um and a provided it's not like an
online game 90 of stuff oh The Game Pass
stuff you can do yeah I was doing
um what you call it can you Dr wrong
yeah but they don't they they need an
official dot you can use like
third-party docs for now and then I
would like that but uh yeah yeah and I
actually tried um remote play uh
PlayStation 5 had a great experience
only thing is I'm gonna have to use um
other methods try to force the use of
PlayStation 5 controller externally
there's methods out there for people who
want to experience is that but um no
it's the same thing you can attach a
controller to you yeah your Bluetooth or
whatever and you can use a you know what
an external controller as opposed to
just using it as a as a handheld yeah no
doubt no doubt yeah those are one of the
questions that I see but um yeah it
could only get better from from this and
I'll just transition to my thoughts on
King's topic which was
um yeah you know look Sony is being
aggressive with the streaming service
now it looks like they transition
transitioning into Cloud streaming which
would be huge for two reasons one
obviously yes the joke would be okay
yeah you're copying Xbox or whatever
okay fine but to me
you know what I look at is as much as I
like Remote Play
I it is janky remoting into my console
at home like what if somebody using the
TV like I'm literally going to dominate
from a remote location right whereas if
I can stream you know I could get it
streaming from their servers that's a
huge deal and then this helps the cue
light because remember we thought the
community light was just uh a remote
only device that's huge if you can also
if you have a good internet connection
you don't have to log into your specific
console that I like so because to me
that's a little janky doing old school
you know doing that so I think that's
cool
um I will say I I have to think it's a
wrap for the partnership with with
Microsoft and Sony that Azure
partnership I think is in the bushes
completely I think because if you look
at um Sony's mentions remember that
because remember King was clowning we
had that top he's like look they're
hiring all these Cloud developers and
Cloud hires and all this other stuff but
if you look at the um job listings it's
all in AWS yes so that to me is an
indicator that that the partnership only
got As far as the talking stages I think
Jim Ryan said it he said we've just been
exchanging ideas I don't think that that
trade ain't gonna happen especially
after ABK and all the mud slinging in
the beef that's in the street that's a
wrap so I think that Sony will be
sticking with AWS going with AWS as far
as their streaming service and they will
be looking to expand I think it's decent
for them to put it in the premium tier I
wouldn't be able to stream my games onto
my allies so I'm all for this please
only get this done I'm a premium member
please I don't want to remote into my
console that's janky yes give me a
proper streaming option and for if
you're gonna give me games that I own
that I could stream and don't force me
to use no PlayStation 5 controllers fan
come on that's old school let me use
whatever device has the inputs that I
want to use on it please you know
Microsoft does not lock me into oh pull
out your Xbox controller and then play
the Ally no no
yeah get your bird dogs on
yeah tight pants come in for me let's
get it oh man let's get it
wow that's different it's very very
different it's very different I
appreciate it I appreciate it appreciate
y'all for dealing with us all that stuff
helps the podcast because you always
we're growing seeing tremendous you know
growth and stuff like that so yeah
salute to y'all supporting that yeah and
when you wear them bird dogs you're
gonna see tremendous growth
y'all need to see all that you rock how
you wanna rock though yeah you all right
let's go oh man we got any Super chances
let me see which ones did you let me see
I'm gonna I'll go backwards here so
probably it's probably about seven
Donald tacos wanting to argue with me
probably
you have to set your time zone on the
Rock Ally or I don't he's saying it as a
statement yeah no he's right so yeah
he's at your time zone make sure
everything's right
and then we have X down the otaku five
dollars I need to have a live debate
with you I'm tired of spending money to
argue with you [__] yo dog you know I
love you brother it's all jokes we can't
argue or beef over subjective opinion
this is not a thing we can defeat but I
love you bro you love your gameplay look
you game players okay I respect that I
respect game players King dudes there's
dudes that's like yo I don't care about
the graphics as long as I could do
something revolutionary new dope and
there's some people that's like yo I
paid this money I want to see this
Hardware push yeah and both can coexist
brother that's all yeah so but it's all
love salute to the kingdom is loose off
it did you get young dread one dreads 52
200 Super Chat King appreciate the Love
on graphic love the show Absolutely
appreciate that kids and we got X Don
Dio Taco that you said wait so you see
the sales of sales but Bethesda games
and Zelda you did that whatever we got
that one okay okay so we're caught up in
that regardless if anything came up on
the bottom spawned
Spartan 661 five dollars which at Happy
Father's Day gentlemen thanks for the
show and enjoy the rest of your day
likewise do we get oh we was only 60
away from getting we almost get a
thousand likes
[Music]
not too messy with the Xbox game
showcase now completed which one of
these first party Xbox game studios has
you most excited not named Starfield
a vowed hellblade too
Fable or Clockwork Revolution we keep it
basic this one we bring back the messy
stuff next week but we want to get a
gauge in the round what's the title that
stuck out the most not named starfish we
want to see what y'all feel about that
that's all I got salute the attic salute
to King again Happy Father's Day to
everyone in the round we appreciate
y'all for coming out here we know
everybody's got their family their life
stuff appreciate the jokes and the love
in the chat solve any fine things you
want to say to the people uh my Happy
Father's Day to all my gold go spend
time with mine right now
um yeah man uh it appreciate y'all being
here for all of this like I said you
know that all these ad reads or whatever
this is this is growth this is growth
and it's because of y'all and the love
y'all show so thank you for putting up
with all with our stupidness and
funnyness to try to make it as
entertaining for y'all as possible and
the fact that y'all respect that allow
us to do a little ad reads and all that
other stuff and get salute to the Xbox
Community
um for obviously running with the whole
you know hold the line but we salute to
the places Community another community
the community for also supporting it
shout out to Gene Park put it in
remember to watch the post join yeah man
oh man it's just been beautiful to see
it and we wouldn't be here without you
guys like at the end of the day the
realm makes it you know what I'm saying
make it happen absolutely which as we
said we're going to be hitting up uh Pax
West this year yeah that's all dude
that's due to you guys that's the first
for for all of us except for congress
who've been there once before so it's
gonna be fun yeah it's gonna be fun
absolutely look that's what I got
everybody enjoying Sunday hug your dad
hug your pops to the pops out there
salute I gotta call Mines up right after
the show have a nice talk anyway
everybody enjoy we about here
[Music]
thank you